Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Moin Leute.
Exzellent.
So, erstmal aufwachen.
Also, ist ja auch Wachen-Stream, passt.
So, ähm, wenn wir gerade dabei sind, dann mache ich doch einfach schon mal Logitech-Zeug
an, weil das aus irgendwelchen Gründen hier nicht automatisch startet, ansonsten geht
mir das immer auf den keks aber hier startet sich automatisch jetzt hat es
das gecheckt ist schön ist es stimmt auch die rgb beleuchtung gut geschlagen
es war relativ warm
was ist denn das hier warum steht da brut
Ach, PXE-Boot.
Okay.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, hier sind random
merkwürdige Dateien, aber nee, das ist okay.
Warum habe ich da eine Rechnung
auf dem Desktop? Egal, das mache ich jetzt nicht auf.
Das ist mal ein Streaming.
Ein Streaming-Windows-Stell ist
hier. Keine Ahnung, warum.
Ach nee, ich weiß, was das ist.
Das ist
Beispielrechnung für die Texterkennung
gewesen, die ich bei Google
irgendwo gesucht habe.
So, muss mal kurz
den Kram wegmachen.
Jaja.
Machen wir mal kurz den Mini-PC
an.
Ah, ich wollte gerade sagen, warum geht das nicht an, aber einfach nur lahm.
BIOS von 2024, müsste man eigentlich mal gucken, ob es da ein neues BIOS-Update gibt.
also nicht ich meine das ding hat keine probleme also aus dem gesichtspunkt
müssen wir kein bios update machen aber mich interessiert einfach mal weil es
ist uns schon so ein china chinesen ding und die hersteller da sind jetzt nicht
unbedingt gerade dafür bekannt sonderlich spendabel zu sein was support
und bios updates angeht
So, da sind wir. Zack.
Chattarino.
Was ist das? ZDF heute?
Bahn, Nahverkehr, Regionalzüge, Verkehrs...
Ey, dieser Keyring da geht mir voll auf den Keks.
Wir stimmen einfach den Cookies zu, wenn juckt's.
Regionalzüge. In allen Bundesländern liegen
Streichlisten. Aha.
Soll mehr Geld für die Schiene geben, damit
kein Karlsruher nachher...
Moment, mehr Geld? Wie mehr Geld?
Ich denke, die haben einen riesigen
Stau, was Geld angeht.
So nach dem Motto, die haben mehr Geld, als sie eigentlich
ausgeben können.
Habe ich mal irgendwie gelesen, vor einer Weile.
Die kommen nicht hinterher
mit Ausbauen
und Zeug.
ein Mysterion.
Was das für Pendler bedeuten könnte,
ja, dass es
im Prinzip beschissen ist
und weiter beschissen bleibt, weil
viel beschissener kann es ja nicht sein.
Wahrscheinlich sind die
die dann fahren sogar pünktlich, aber wenn wir nicht
da fahren.
Länderwahnvorstreichung.
Kosten für Schienenverkehr steigt.
Ja, ach. Warum sollte es da anders sein
als beim Rest?
Ich habe letztens einen guten Screenshot gemacht von der Übersichtsseite Züge am Frankfurter
Hauptbahnhof und die war wirklich mein komplettes Handy.
Also die komplette Seite auf dem Handy von oben bis unten war alles rot und nicht einfach
nur fünf Minuten oder so.
Da waren ICEs teilweise, die sollten um 11 Uhr fahren, sind um 14 Uhr gefahren und sowas.
Ja gut, das kann ich verstehen.
Und es gibt wahrscheinlich auch immer weniger Leute, die, also jetzt nicht nur Firmen, die für die Bahn arbeiten wollen,
sondern es gibt wahrscheinlich auch immer weniger Leute, die für die Bahn arbeiten wollen.
Was ich auch verstehen kann, ich meine die Bahn ist unbeliebt as fuck.
Du musst dich permanent mit irgendwelchen Leuten rumschlagen, die zu Recht am Ausrasten sind.
So.
Machen wir mal Update.
Und dann...
Eigentlich richtig dumm.
Ich mache jetzt...
Okay, ich mache ein Update.
Aber ich reboote nicht, weil ich habe jetzt extra überall alles gestoppt.
gestartet, angeordnet, hingeschoben
und jetzt mache ich Reboot und dann sind wir weg.
Man kann in KDE
glaube ich auch so eine Session
speichern irgendwie, dass es dann
immer wieder so aufgemacht wird.
Wird es übelst Bock, als Software-Dev
für die Bahn zu wirken?
Aber die haben auch nur Kackstellen ausgeschrieben
Wollen wir mal gucken?
Wollen wir mal gerade gucken, was die so haben?
Lass uns mal kurz gucken
Bahn, Karriere
Okay, schauen wir mal
Während des Updates
Alles akzeptieren
Ich bin
Okay, ich bin
Ich habe ein Berufsamt, ich habe ein Abgeschlossen
Und Berufserfahrung, okay
Windows 3.11, ja
Gibt's ja
Ich hab letztens übrigens was gelesen
Bahn Linux-Sperre
Irgendwie sowas
Hier, guck mal, das da
Das gab's letztens in den News
Ähm
Dass wohl zunehmend
Leute, die
Die sie identifizieren können
Von Linux aus
bei der Verbindungssuche gesperrt werden.
Also wahrscheinlich erkennen die das irgendwie anhand von irgendeinem Browser-Fingerprint,
den sie machen oder anhand vom User-Agent.
Wobei ich dachte eigentlich, der User-Agent unterscheidet sich jetzt nicht mehr zwischen Browsern großartig.
Hatten die das nicht so, dass man quasi schlechter Fingerprinten kann?
Naja, probieren wir das doch mal aus.
Bahn.de
Okay, wir sind ja eindeutig unter Linux.
Wir erlauben alle Cookies.
So, von Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir gesperrt werden.
Von Frankfurt nach Köln.
Suchen.
Außer, dass es lahm ist.
Was aber auch hier am Dark-Rede liegen könnte.
So, wie oft muss man...
Kann man noch irgendwie updaten oder so?
Wie oft muss man jetzt hier klicken, dass man ausgesperrt wird?
Was ist schon passiert?
Okay, anscheinend...
Anscheinend wurde ich nicht ausgesperrt.
Probieren wir nochmal.
Muss ich vielleicht...
Okay, okay, okay.
Äh, Claw?
Wie mir dieser Kack-Keyring auf den Sack geht.
Kann man das nicht einfach irgendwie komplett disablen?
Wir haben da schon...
Ah!
Das da?
Guck mal.
Ich wurde ausgesperrt.
Also Firefox ist anscheinend nicht betroffen.
Firefox ist anscheinend nicht betroffen.
Chrome schon.
Guck mal.
Lass mal kurz gucken, ob es bei Firefox noch funktioniert.
Firefox geht.
Firefox juckt nicht.
Chrome?
Chrome mag nicht.
Bitte verwenden Sie einen anderen Browser.
Lehren Sie den Cache Ihres...
Ja, ist klar, Bahn.
Verwenden Sie einen anderen Internet, falls Sie einen VPN-Client,
falls Sie buchen als Gast und nicht wirklich...
Jaja, ihr könnt mich mal...
Oder wegen der Session, du hast recht.
Das kann auch sein.
Probieren wir nochmal.
Ne, ich darf nicht.
Komma witzig block stellt
Die bahn die bahn blockt doch tatsächlich linux user
Und die bahn sagt dass sie das nicht machen wie man ja eben hier wie man sieht die bahn macht das nicht
Ihr seht dass die bahn das nicht macht
Offensichtlich ist es nicht geblockt gerade.
Splixer, danke schön für den Zap.
Fehlalarme möglich.
In seltenen Fällen.
Jaja.
Okay, heiße Kommentare.
Sind bestimmt wieder wild dazu.
Äh, by the way, die Bahnseite ist zwar ganz gut, um Verbindungen zu suchen und wie man da fahren muss und was es für Züge gibt auf einer Strecke von A nach B.
Wenn man aber wirklich wissen will, ob seine Züge pünktlich sind, ja, oder wie der Status der einzelnen Züge ist, dann müsst ihr auf Bahn.expert, viel besser.
Bahn.expert.
Ja, und dann könnt ihr jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, Frankfurt und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, oder was.
Guck mal, es ist erstaunlich pünktlich gerade Frankfurt alles hier.
So, dann sagt er jetzt hier zum Beispiel
Keine Ahnung, den da
Max, warum braucht Darkweeder
Eigentlich so ressourcintensiv
Naja, ich vermute mal, weil der halt die komplette
Das komplette HTML der Webseite
Scant und dann da irgendwelche
Sachen manipuliert
Ich könnte mir vorstellen
Das geht nicht viel effektiver
Vielleicht ist Darkweeder aber einfach
Nur Schrott und es gibt mittlerweile ein besseres
Hier seht ihr dann
Alles ganz genau, unter anderem
halt auch, ob der Zug wirklich
abgefahren ist an der Stelle und sowas.
Also ich finde Bahn.expert ist
für Statusinformationen über
einen Zug viel, viel, viel
besser als
die Bahnseite selbst.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob das Font-Rendering, ob das hier bei Chrome besser aussehen würde.
Nee, das sieht genauso kacke aus, okay.
Aber wen juckt das Font-Rendering?
Max, hast du mitbekommen, dass sie ihre Statusmeldung...
Nee, weiß jetzt nicht, was du meinst.
Mal davon abgesehen, die Bahn verkackt laufend.
Aber wir wollten ja eigentlich gucken, was die Bahn so für Jobs anbietet gerade.
oder weil jemand geschrieben hat, ist alles Schrott.
Gucken wir mal.
Einen Job im IT-Bereich suchen wir, okay?
Jetzt informieren.
Kennst du strecken.info?
Nee.
Äh.
Oder auch nicht.
Da sind plötzlich interne Meldungen im Navigator aufgetaucht.
Ach ja.
Tja, das verstehe ich auch nicht.
Streckeninfo.
Okay, und was kann man da jetzt machen?
Modus.
Filter.
Strecken, Betriebsstellen.
Frankfurt.
Was? Frankfurt Autobahn?
Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof?
Und, und, und, äh.
Baustelle.
Ach, du kannst auf der Karte gucken,
ob was gesperrt ist.
Okay.
Ist aber nur der hier.
Ich mach mal den Filter wieder raus.
Also scrollen wir mal hier rein.
Gehen wir nach Gelnhausen
zum Beispiel. Aha, da sieht man
dass hier Zeug gesperrt ist.
Weil Baustelle.
Hier ist auch, guck mal hier, Hanau ist auch Zeug gesperrt.
Störung.
Main-Tal-Ost.
Störung BZI 26660.
Okay, äh, was sagt einem das jetzt?
Also ich meine, es gibt eine Störung, das ist schon mal gut zu wissen, aber BZI weiß ich nicht.
Was ist das?
So, was haben wir denn in Hanau noch?
Hier runter ist noch was.
1F097.20
Weichenerneuerung steht da, okay.
Stand hier auch irgendwas?
Gefährliches Ereignis.
Aha.
Okay.
Okay, die Seite muss ich mir merken.
Ich habe jetzt zwar nicht so eine
Daily-Anwendung dafür, aber so ab und zu
ist das mal nicht verkehrt.
Oh, machen wir hier mal wieder zu.
Also, dein Job als IT-
Professional.
Wir waren übrigens gerade noch.
Ich mach mal kurz noch eine Sache fertig, weil ansonsten kann ich
mich vergessen.
Ich will noch Updates fertig machen.
Ist hier Updates? Jawohl.
Rast wird geupdatet.
Nein, Rastrover
wird geupdatet.
Rider Sea Line.
Okay, update mal.
Rust.
Okay, so, was hat denn die Bahn am Start?
Einstiegsbereich Agile
Was soll ich mir darunter vorstellen?
Du bist das Scrum Master dann, oder was?
Okay, gucken wir mal
Alle IT-Jobs kompakt
Wähle Bundesland.
Hessen.
Frankfurter Main.
Verfügbare St...
Das ist alles?
Mehr gibt's nicht?
Okay.
Was haben wir denn?
F, R, M, C, S.
Okay, hätte ich gar keine Ahnung, was das überhaupt sein soll.
F, R...
Warte.
Oh mein Gott.
F, R, M, C, S.
Was ist das?
future railway mobile communication ist im 5g basierend nachfolger das so dass
man weiß wo die züge sind oder irgendwie sowas
was.
Ne, bin ich nicht.
IT-Netzwerk-Administrator.
Projektleiter.
Okay, die
Stellen sacken aber wirklich alle richtig hart.
Okay, was ist, wenn man
Einstiegsbereich Development macht.
Gibt's nicht.
Äh, ja.
Wer auch immer gerade gesagt hat,
die Stellen sacken, ja, die Stellen sacken.
Projektleiter, Produktmanager,
ne, geh mal bloß weg.
Teamkoordinator, MonKS.
Ja, Hessen.
Schau mal, deutschlandweit, okay.
Wo du willst, Job.
Aha.
Cyber Defense.
Java Backend.
Okay, immerhin mal eine Sache.
Also, nicht, dass ich das machen wollen würde,
noch, dass ich das machen könnte, aber...
Ich suche hier eh nix.
Okay, wähle dein Bundesland.
Man muss ein Bundesland wählen.
Man kann nicht deutschlandweit gucken.
Bayern.
München.
Tja.
Ist die Bahn nicht irgendwo in Köln oder so?
Hauptsitz mäßig?
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Tja.
Berlin?
Berlin, okay.
Ah, hier gibt es, guck mal.
Hier gibt es tatsächlich ein paar Sachen
Senior
Systemadministrator
Clients und Server
Clients klingt so nach Windows Laptops
Okay gucken wir mal
Ah Berlin ist schon richtig
Paints Champ Alter
Jetzt bewerben
naja ehrlich gesagt selbst selbst wenn ich den job suchen würde wahrscheinlich
ich bei der bahn ok sie suchen ein systemadministrator clients und server
männlich weiß deutsch für die db infra go ag erst halb jetzt wailand moment
was ist das diese abgift dieses wallet man wie mir das auf den sack geht
kann ich das mal verpisst es ist not a joke das ist minecraft was
Wayland Compositor
for Minecraft.
Moment, Moment.
Heißt das jetzt...
Moment, das kann ich mir jetzt gar nicht
vorstellen, was das genau ist.
Heißt das jetzt
Minecraft?
Ich hab echt keine Ahnung,
wie ich mir das vorstelle. Das können wir uns gleich
angucken. Ich habe echt keine Ahnung, wie ich mir das vorstellen darf.
Also lass mal kurz gucken,
was will die Bahn denn haben?
Kern deiner Arbeit ist
die Betriebsführung der zentral geführten
Techniken der... Okay, bla bla bla.
Alter, das ist
so ein typischer HR
Nichts sagen der Satz.
Kern deiner Arbeit ist die Betriebsführung
der zentral geführten Techniken...
Was? Ja, was wollt ihr denn jetzt eigentlich genau?
Die Betriebsführung der zentral geführten Techniken. Aha.
Das beinhaltet Konfiguration, Administration, Monitoring sowie die Mitwirkung bei der Weiterentwicklung dieser Systeme.
Die Einführung unter Betrieb automatisierter Installation Konfigurationslösungen.
Informationslösung, IT-Sicherheitsassessments und unterstützt das IT-Sicherheitsvorfallmanagement bei der Bearbeitung und Behebung von IT-Vorfällen und der Durchführung von IT-Risiken und Bedrohungsanlässigungen.
Koordination der bereichsübergreifenden internen als auch externen Zusammenarbeit mit Partnern sowie...
Und dann übernimmst du die Dokumentation der Systemlandschaft.
Okay, naja, das ist jetzt ja sehr high level, was man hier sieht.
Erfahrung im Betrieb von Windows-Servern.
Und Virtualisierungsumgebung.
VmWare, KVM und irgendwas von Red Hat.
Das habe ich noch nie in the wild gesehen.
Red Hat Enterprise Virtualization.
MonkaS, Alter.
Nachdem die Weiterentwicklung bereits 2020 eingestellt wurde,
läuft der erweiterte Support im Jahr 2026 vollständig aus.
Nice.
Hauptsache die Bahn haben nochmal irgendein ekliges Legacy-System am Start.
Sucht hier zufällig jemand einen Linux-Cloud-Entwicklungsjob in Münster?
Ja, Chat. Eure Chance jetzt.
Linux Bash, Python, Perl sind für dich keine Fremdwörter,
sondern gehören in einer komplexen Systemlandschaft dazu.
Aber muss das... Aber Pearl!
Naja, irgendwelche Legacy-Dinger wahrscheinlich noch in Pearl, ja.
Ach so, Metal Hydra. Ich hab gedacht, du bist irgendwie Teamleiter und suchst Leute oder so.
du weißt, es wird was frei, weil du weg bist.
Mit Management-Systemen
und Konfigurationstools
Moment, mit Management-Systemen
für die Server- und Klient-Administration
bist du bereit. Ja, da gibt es ja auch nur eins.
Ja.
Wie wäre es, wenn die halt sagen, was?
Hervorragende
Deutsch- und Englischkenntnisse.
Da steht jetzt ehrlich gesagt
Irgendwie
Ein bisschen Chat
An sich finde ich die Stellenanzeige okay
Das ist glücklicherweise
wenig, wenig bla bla bla bla
ähm
aber, ne, also
wenig, so nach dem Motto, die deutsche Bahn
ist das führende bla bla bla bla bla
aber es hat ein bisschen
wenig, so ein bisschen
wenig Substanz, was sie jetzt eigentlich genau
wollen, oder? Ich mein
die, die, die wollen, die wollen hier auf der
einen Seite
Windows-Servern und hier
schreiben sie was von Linux Bash
Python Perl. Ja, wie jetzt?
Wenn die ein Windows-Admin suchen,
dann...
Dann das hier?
Also, die suchen jemanden, der
Windows-Virtualisierung
und Linux... Also, das könnte man schon
auch ein bisschen klarer schreiben, was da jetzt eigentlich
Sache ist.
Also, finde ich jetzt nicht so geil.
Aber gut, ich meine, es ist die Bahn.
Hatten die sonst noch irgendwas Spannendes?
Senior Frontend Engineer
haben sie noch. Na, da bin ich jetzt
immer gespannt.
Die Eisenbahn
der Zukunft.
Langjährige Erfahrung in der Frontend-Entwicklung
Mindestens 8 Jahre
Du bringst fundiertes Wissen im modernen Frontend-React-Type-Script mit
Figma.
Ist das jetzt nicht so vor einer Weile gewesen, dass irgendwie alle von Figma abgesprungen sind, weil die irgendwas komisches getrieben haben?
Ich habe da aber irgendwann ein Video auf YouTube zugesehen von irgendeinem Frontend-HTML-Design-Channel.
Das Figma gar nicht mehr so angesagt ist.
Web-Technologie zum Beispiel.
Okay, da hat irgendjemand gesagt, also derjenige, der das geschrieben hat.
Webseite, zum Beispiel Rest.
Ja, das stimmt schon, aber das ist so...
Das ist wie wenn ich sage...
Das Verwenden einer Tastatur, so.
Ah ja.
Homeoffice, aha, Moment.
Stand das beim Server-Admin auch drin?
Das stand da nicht drin, Homeoffice, gell?
Ah, guck mal
Der Frontend-Entwickler
Der darf im Homeoffice arbeiten
Der Server-Admin
Nicht
Was darauf
Schließen lässt
Dass man dort vor Ort
Sachen machen muss
Auf
Line-Support-mäßig
oder ins Rechenzentrum
und sowas. Deswegen gibt's
hier kein Homeoffice.
Tja.
Naja, aber so wirklich geil
So wirklich geil ist das jetzt
tatsächlich nicht gewesen.
Was die Bahn da zu bieten hat.
Bevor wir das hier gucken,
wobei, komm, wir gucken das jetzt.
Und danach gucken wir Github.
Trends.
Das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich.
Minecraft als Wayland-Kompositor.
Oh, Mokka S.
Das ist Minecraft.
Jetzt, du bist nicht auf dem falschen Kanal.
Klick nicht gerade.
Lass mich erklären.
So oft kommt ein Minecraft-Moder mit einer Idee,
wo ich denke, ich weiß nicht, warum du das machst.
Zum Beispiel kam jemand mit,
effektiv, Git für Minecraft-Werden,
so you can revert to older iterations of the world.
I didn't make a video on this at the time,
but the devs' video is very good, so go and check that out.
More recently though, and something people have been talking quite a bit about,
is a Wayland Compositor in Minecraft.
Yes, I am being...
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Also Minecraft ist ja normalerweise eine Anwendung,
die
keine Ahnung
in irgendeinem Fenster
unter irgendeinem Kompositor läuft
wie das
hä?
Ich kann es mir absolut null vorstellen gerade
wie darf ich
100%
serious here, this is not a
virtual machine, this is running
the actual apps
on your system
much like with the ratty terminal
you might be asking
Why?
By the end of this video, I still won't have an answer for you.
Habt ihr das gesehen mit dem Reti-Terminal?
Das ist ein Terminal, was 3D-Models laden kann.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht.
Ach ja, und der Cursor ist eine Ratte.
But what I can say is that it is really, really cool.
So let's go and give it a shot.
If we go and press V, that opens the application launcher.
If I search for Alacrity for a terminal,
we now have a terminal window in our hotbar.
Ach so ist das!
Jetzt verstehe ich, was sie da gemacht haben.
Okay, ich konnte es mir am Anfang gar nicht vorstellen.
Wie darf ich mir einen Wayland-Kompositoren mit Minecraft vorstellen?
Ach so, du hast quasi einen Anwendungs-Launcher in Minecraft
und kannst dann da drinnen die Fenster in deine Minecraft-Welt rendern.
Eigentlich eine richtig geile Idee, oder?
kann ich mit dem Mauskontrollen gehen und den Text auswählen.
Es ist natürlich ein bisschen schrecklich, das in 3D-Grunden zu tun,
aber es funktioniert.
Wenn wir den Eck eines Fensters nehmen,
können wir es und resizieren.
Wir können auch Diagonale machen.
Wiederum sehr schrecklich, das in 3D-Grunden zu tun.
Auch wenn wir die Bar hier hinnehmen,
können wir es und bewegen.
Schaut, dass ihr das hier tun könnt
und es weit außerhalb eurer Range platziert.
Also, einfach vorsichtig sein, das zu machen.
Jetzt, wenn du das aufgrund der Unwahrheit machst und du nicht gehen willst, um das Fenster runter zu schießen,
wenn du einfach das Fenster wiederhälten willst,
Hatte quasi seine Programme dann in Skyrim drin.
Bisschen sowas wie hier.
Eigentlich würde, also ich könnte das richtig gut verwenden bei mir.
Weil ich arbeite ja hauptsächlich remote über Citrix.
Und das ist dann halt, da wird dann hier halt der Citrix-Client reingerendert.
Und dann kann ich hier Minecraft Home Office machen.
Was mich jetzt interessieren würde, geht Copy-Paste.
Geht Copy-Paste. Das würde mich interessieren.
Also nicht nur in einem Terminal, sondern von einem zum anderen Terminal und sowas.
Ja, gut.
Ich würde nochmal einen Browser installieren.
Immer noch besser als Metaverse, sagt der Chat.
Metaverse
ist ein Wort
was ich lange nicht mehr gehört habe
das ist doch auch mittlerweile
dead, oder?
Keine Sau hat sich für diese Geschichte bei Facebook
interessiert
Ist das dann einfach sein OS oder emuliert?
Das ist sein OS, also was heißt sein OS?
Sein Wayland Compositor
ist das
Also so wie ich
So wie ich hier KDE habe
Wird dann halt da Minecraft gestartet
Und darin kannst du deine Anwendungen starten
So verstehe ich das
Metaverse ist komplett dead gewatt
Jetzt muss ich jetzt mal gucken
Ihr habt mich jetzt gerade wieder auf was
Auf was gebracht
Da habe ich ja lange nichts mehr von gehört
Ey ey ey
Oh Gott ey
Metaverse is the future of digital connection.
Also anscheinend gibt es den Mist immer noch.
Die haben einfach die Webseite nicht runtergenommen, oder?
Ich glaube, die Webseite ist einfach nur noch da.
Ja, Marc...
Ja, okay.
Mark Zuckerberg
dreht dem Metaverse den Saft ab.
Ich will es jetzt ja nicht sagen,
aber ich sag es trotzdem mal.
Ich hab's euch ja gesagt.
Ich hatte echt keine Ahnung,
wer den Kram verwenden sollte.
Vor allem könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern.
Wo er das gezeigt hat, dieses Bild, und irgendwie so getan hat, als wäre das jetzt mega geile Errungenschaft.
Irgendwas, was aussieht wie aus dem Game, vor 30 Jahren.
Das war eines der ersten Bilder, die damals metaverse-technisch gezeigt wurden.
was halt innerhalb von, also dieses Ding kannst du wahrscheinlich mit jeder x-beliebigen Game Engine in 5 Minuten machen.
So, gucken wir mal weiter auf Minecraft.
Wayland.
Das ist nicht mal Wii Sport.
Wii Sport war hübscher.
Jetzt können wir viel mehr auswählen, als wir wollen und das ist völlig in Ordnung.
Drücken wir wieder Alt-Q, nehmen wir uns aus diesem Modus.
Ihr könnt euch fragen, wie wir Alt-Q und Escape gleichzeitig machen.
From here, again, if we press G, we can start typing as you would normally expect.
Das Font-Rendering ist halt ein bisschen kaputt, ne?
But let's just go and find some...
Wobei, nicht nur das Font-Rendering, das ganze Rendering.
Aber gut, ist ja irgendwie auch klar, das ist ein 2D-Fenster, was irgendwie 3D-gerendert wird.
Kein Wunder, dass es ein bisschen pixelig ist, ne?
Das ist danach gekippt und...
Cat Pictures.
Das ist cool.
Ja, das ist cool, dass das sogar funktioniert.
Du kannst sogar Window Management mit diesem Minecraft-Wayland-Kompositor machen.
Ja.
Ich find's witzig, dass man die neue Fenster dann in der Hand hat bei Minecraft,
da wo er seine Kamera drüber hat.
Ich scroll trotzdem mal ein bisschen vor.
Monka S.
Gimp mit den Multiple Fensters, das wird ja was.
Ja.
Oh, da bin ich ja mal gespannt auf das Funds.
Ja, das ist schon cool.
Also, da sieht man, da ist echt einiges auch an Energie reingeflossen, das zu programmieren.
Das ist jetzt nicht einfach mal so komplett dahin gekackt.
Das funzt ja sogar richtig.
Und da unten hat man eine Taskleiste.
Eigentlich ist das eine mega geile Idee.
Nicht, dass ich es irgendwie verwenden würde.
Ja.
Kann man damit Minecraft in Minecraft starten?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Wüsste nicht, wüsste nicht warum.
für alle unsere Applikationen.
Wenn man mehr einfach etwas benutzen möchte,
ist das ein traditioneller Weg,
um mit diesen Wienern zu interagieren.
Aber es ist immerhin noch in Minecraft.
Es gibt Limitationen, was man hier tun kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie...
Geht Audio?
Naja, man hat eben Klick, Klick, Klick gehört.
Ich weiß nicht, ob...
Mal gucken, ob Videos, Video-Audio und so funktioniert.
Wie viel ist die Limitation der Minecraft-Moding-Interface?
Wie viel ist die Limitation...
Der erste ist der Halt-Button.
Wir gehen erstmal ein bisschen vor.
Du kannst Minecraft spielen und dabei ein Video im Overlay haben.
Aber kein Sound, hä?
Es hat Sound.
I have a controller plugged in.
Okay?
Ja, du kannst auch Minecraft in Minecraft starten, bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Also ja.
Ja, theoretisch könnte man Minecraft in Minecraft spielen.
Aber, obwohl ich die Werte davon gesehen habe,
hat es einige sehr klare Bedingungen.
Wir gucken jetzt mal kurz das GitHub-Repo an.
Also wer auf sowas steht, kann ja mal Stern da lassen.
Was mich jetzt interessiert ist tatsächlich, wie vibe-coded sieht das Ganze aus?
Gar nicht vibe-coded.
Sieht gar nicht großartig
vibe-coded aus.
Uncoded, Leute.
Na dann.
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Waycraft?
GitHub?
Nee, Waylandcraft?
Irgendwie so?
Alter, ich kann ja...
Ja.
Waylandcraft.
Lass mal kurz gucken, ob es das hier irgendwie im Arch-User-Repo gibt.
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Okay.
Wie kriegt man das installiert?
Ja.
Okay, wir laden das jetzt mal kurz runter.
Chat, ich bin ja überhaupt kein Minecraft-Checker.
Wie startet man das jetzt?
So?
Ach so, ich brauche erstmal ein funktionierendes Minecraft.
Das ist kein Standalone Minecraft.
Okay, ne, habe ich nicht.
Ach, das ist ein Minecraft-Mod.
Also sprich, ich brauche ein funktionierendes Minecraft.
Und dann muss ich den Mod installieren.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ne, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir gucken jetzt mal.
Kannst du mal ein bisschen gedudelt werden machen wieder.
Gucken jetzt mal, was auf GitHub so trendet.
Was haben wir denn diese Woche Schönes?
Fangen wir mal an.
Mit allgemeinen GitHub Trends.
AI
Nicht AI
Glowbrowser, das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon
Das hab ich mir sogar gebuckmarkt
Das war das letzte Mal ein Projekt, wo ich gesagt hab
Ey, das könnte man tatsächlich mal gebrauchen
Ein Chromium Browser, den man fernsteuern kann, der in keinen Bot Detection Tests auffällt.
Angeblich.
AI.
Okay, super.
Perfekte, tolle Trends diese Woche wieder.
Language.
Was trendet denn in...
Gucken wir mal bei den Krustentieren zuerst heute.
AI.
Hatten wir das letzte Mal schon.
Bun trendet.
Witzig, dass Bun jetzt komplett Rust steht.
Haben die die SICK-Geschichte rausgeschmissen?
Nee, ist immer noch drin.
Aber es ist jetzt mehr Rust als SICK.
Okay, verstehe.
Leute, ich sag's jetzt nochmal
Ich hab's letztes Mal glaube ich schon gesagt
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen
Dass diese
Sig zu Rust
Transformation
Die Ban da gemacht hat
Das Ende von Ban ist
Weil ich hab so den Eindruck
Das ist so eine typische Geschichte
Mal wieder von Entropic
wo sie zeigen wollen wir haben eine javascript runtime mit hilfe von ai rewritten in rust wie
gut da kam jetzt funktioniert keine ahnung ich habe da so meine zweifel also ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass das der anfang vom ende von bahn ist weil user haben echt keinen bock
zwei jahre zu warten bis man wieder was erreicht hat was man den sick schon hatte und vor allem
dass es dann so auch funktioniert, wie es in SIG funktioniert hat, auch bei allen Edge Cases.
Habe ich so meine Zweifel?
Auf der anderen Seite, um da mal ein bisschen dagegen zu halten,
der Rust Port ist ja wirklich ein Port.
Also das ist kein Rewrite in Rust in dem Sinn, das ist ein Port zu Rust.
Also sprich, das ist quasi der SIG-Code nur in Rust.
Also besteht auch quasi fast komplett aus Unsafe-Code in Rust.
Also da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich hab den Eindruck, das ist wieder so eine Geschichte von
Anthropic, weil Anthropic, die Cloud-Code-Leute
haben ja Bann gekauft vor einer Weile.
Das ist so ein Marketing-Ding von denen
wieder, wo sie dann einen Post drüber
machen können.
Und ein bisschen ihr AI-Kram hypen.
Guck mal, 5000 Issues.
Hatten die früher auch so viele?
Ritme ist still, sei es beinahe zu spritzend.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die früher auch so krass viele neue Issues hatten.
Die hatten bestimmt früher auch Issues, aber...
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das der Anfang vom Ende von Bann ist.
Jared ist der Bun-Typ, der jetzt bei Anthropic arbeitet.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich bin da skeptisch.
Ich meine, Anthropic hat ja schon mehr solche Dinger gemacht, solche Marketing-Aktionen.
Erinnert sich noch einer an...
C-Compiler from scratch.
Wo halt nichts funktioniert hat.
Die haben angeblich from scratch
einen C-Compiler mit...
mit...
mit Claws sicherstellen lassen.
So.
und es funktioniert halt nix richtig.
Das war auch so ein Marketing-Ding.
Da sieht man auch,
das war halt mal so ein Marketing-Stunt
von drei Monaten.
Danach interessiert es halt keine Sau mehr.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ast-Crab.
Written in Rust.
Placingly fast.
A DLI-Tool for Code-Structural-Search.
Lint and re...
Was für ein Ding?
Ast-Crab.
Irgendwie erinnert mich das ein bisschen daran,
zu meiner Schulzeit.
Da gab es Leute, die fanden
sich ganz furchtbar cool.
Die haben damals
Ich denke nicht,
dass das heute noch ein Ding ist.
Damals war man cool, wenn man
einen Eastpack-Rucksack hat.
So, und was Leute damals
gemacht haben ist, die haben das
eh mit dem schwarzen Edding
weggemalt. Okay.
Und hier die T-Dinger.
mit einem schwarzen Edding weggemalt.
Und dann stand dann da, ASI-Pack.
Und das fanden die Leute damals ganz geil.
Und haben sich gedacht, boah, ich bin jetzt voll der krasse Checker,
weil ich einen ASI-Pack-Rucksack habe.
Gucken wir, ob es da sogar noch Bilder von gibt.
Ja, ja.
Genau.
So sah das dann damals aus, ja.
Und da hat man sich dann wahnsinnig cool gefühlt mit...
Azipak.
Exakt.
Irgendwie hat mich dieser Name da dran erinnert
Was ist denn Astgrep?
Astgrep ist das CLI-Tool
for Code Structural Search, Lint and Rewriting
Ah ja
Ah, das ist ein Greptool, was quasi die Syntax versteht
beziehungsweise den Syntax Tree.
Und was bringt mir das jetzt genau?
Okay, bin ich zu dumm für?
Lean CT, okay, AI.
AI.
Ja, nicht AI.
Rustnet.
Per Process Network Monitor
for your terminal with deep package inspection.
Oh, was ist das denn?
IP-Leak, Leute.
Per Process Network Monitor.
Das ist ja cool.
Da kann man sich quasi angucken, was einzelne Programme für Netzwerktraffic...
Kannst du bitte AI löschen? Das geht leider nicht.
Man kann hier... Ich bin ja dafür, GitHub würde so einen AI-Tag einführen, dass man das einfach rausfiltern kann, aber das geht nicht.
Oder du meinst, ich soll einfach AI komplett löschen, weltweit.
Ja, easy.
Ist gelöscht
AI ist nicht mehr, Leute
Ich hab AI gelöscht
Einfach deleted
Wobei, ich hab's in den Papierkorb
gemovet, dass man's theoretisch wieder
restauren kann
Okay, Voyager-Trends machen wir jetzt
New
AI
Guck
Bam
Ist weg
Zeitalter von AI
Wobei
Können wir heute ein Morpheus Video anschauen
Ja wenn es da ein interessantes
Neues gibt
Das ist ein cooles Projekt, das bookmark ich mir mal.
Ich habe jetzt keinen direkten Anwendungsfall für.
Aber,
ich habe mich auf der Arbeit
manchmal schon öfters gefragt,
also muss ich ein bisschen ausholen, ja.
Manchmal haben wir uns auf der Arbeit gefragt,
so wird diese firewall regel noch gebraucht und du kannst bei der firewall regel dann gucken okay
da gehen packages drüber oder du kannst es nicht direkt gucken aber jetzt verkleidet können das
gucken da sieht man okay ja die firewall regel wird noch gebraucht aber das problem ist dass
also viele ganz alte firewall regeln haben halt nichts gescheites dabei dran stehen du weißt
ehrlich gesagt nicht genau wofür die da ist und das ist teilweise gar nicht so einfach raus zu
zu finden unter linux also man kriegt das schon raus ja aber es teilweise gar nicht so einfach
rauszufinden wenn das traffic ist der selten vorkommt was das jetzt eigentlich ist und was
das eigentlich jetzt benutzt ja gerade wenn es custom ports sind port 80 80 ja kann theoretisch
alles sein als als target listening ist einfach wissen den kriegste raus aber
wenn er einmal am tag irgendwas traffic macht das ist gar nicht so einfach
rauszukriegen wenn du kriegst du mit netzwerken mussten
darauf zeichnen du kriegst du das auch raus aber so was wäre vielleicht echt
ganz cool
interessant das muss ich mir mal bookmarken
AI?
Wobei, warum ist das noch da?
Achso, Moment.
Ach Leute, jetzt weiß ich.
Ich hab den Browser...
Ich hab AI gelöscht, aber ich hab den Browser noch nicht refreshed.
Deswegen ist da noch AI da.
Ich refresh mal.
Zack, AI weg.
Effortless, Compose, Extend and Observe every Service in...
Was soll denn das sein?
I, I, I, I.
Hä?
Chat, das ist mir zu hoch.
Ich checke nicht, was ich hier sehen bin.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Point to Point Integrations
N, N-1 durch 2
Irgendwelche Spieleempfehlung aktuell?
Ne
Ich muss sagen
ich spiele gerade wieder
Herr der Ringe Online. Das ist ein uraltes
MMO, was wahrscheinlich den wenigsten
von euch gefallen wird, das sage ich gleich.
Aber ich spiele halt
gerne Oldschool MMOs.
Und nachdem die Dark Age of Eden,
die Dark Age of Camelot Season
sich, also schon
sehr weit fortgeschritten ist, spiele ich gerade ein bisschen
was anderes.
PoE 2 Patch, habe ich irgendwie keinen Bock drauf.
Ich bin immer gespannt, wie das mit PoE und PoE 2 weitergeht.
Weil PoE 2 ist ja bei weitem noch nicht fertig.
Und die werden ja auch PoE 1 nicht einfach ersetzen, weil da auch viel Geld mit noch gemacht wird.
Also keine Ahnung, ob das dann einfach...
Also es wird wahrscheinlich drauf rauslaufen, dass das eine ganze Weile parallel läuft und dann langsam PoE 1 ausgefadet wird oder so.
Die müssen halt aber drauf achten, weil PoE 1 hat halt auch viele Fans, die nicht so happy sind mit PoE 2 und die willst du ja auch nicht verlieren.
Ja, es sollte auch parallel laufen, aber auf lange Sicht, die lassen doch keine zwei Games mit gleichem Support im Endeffekt.
das wird drauf rauslaufen, dass das 2er
dann 80% der Entwickler und das 1er
20% der Entwickler kriegt und dann wird
das irgendwann ausfaden.
Hast du Expedition 33 fertig?
Ne. Immer noch nicht weitergespielt
sein im letzten Mal. Ich bin jetzt
irgendwo in der Art Akt 3.
Da wo man dann quasi
fliegen kann und alles.
Habe ich nicht fertig gespielt, ne.
Aber das Spiel hat echt einen
nice Soundtrack.
So, okay. Also ich habe
keine Ahnung, was ich hier sehend bin, ehrlich gesagt.
Worker Function
Trigger.
Okay, whatever.
Äh, immer noch AI.
Ich hab doch AI gelöscht.
Python Free Rust Interference Server.
Okay, AI.
Vault One.
Lightning Fast and Powerful Code Editor.
Ne, das brauchen wir jetzt halt noch mehr.
Gucken wir mal, was in Go trendet.
Nur ein bisschen schneller.
sollen sie machen wie bei overwatch ja du hast alles problem bei p1 und p2 das
p1 sehr viele fans hat die nicht glücklich sind mit p2 willst du dir
wirklich verlieren ich weiß nicht was sie machen also ich
bin echt mal gespannt
High Performance Self Hosted Newsletter und Mailing List Manager.
Es gibt Leute die wirklich regelmäßig Mailing Listen benutzen.
Ich weiß Linux Kernel Development und so Mailing Liste, aber ganz ehrlich.
Ich mache jetzt seit 2000...
Also beruflich mache ich das seit 2007.
Verdiene ich mit Linux mein Geld.
Und ich glaube, ich kann es an einer Hand abzählen.
Wo ich mal...
Mailing-Listen angucken musste.
ei ei ei
why is it running
äh wie
achso
da kannst du gucken
kannst du dir quasi Infos zu Ports
zu Ports und so
ja eigentlich ganz cool
werde ich aber nicht verwenden
aus dem gleichen Grund
wie ich die meisten anderen Tools
die nicht standardmäßig bei Linux
zur Verfügung stehen, nicht benutze ist.
Ich brauche das ja auf Server und nicht lokal auf meiner Kiste.
Und da habe ich die ganzen advanced Tools nicht.
Also bei mir
gibt es zwei Stufen von Tools.
Oder sagen wir mal drei Stufen von Tools.
So, das erste ist, es gibt Tools,
die auf jeder Linux-Kiste verfügbar sind.
Und damit habe ich überhaupt
keine Schmerzen, die zu verwenden.
Das nächste ist,
sind Tools, die
zwar nicht die vorn auf jeder
Linienkiste drauf sind, aber höchstwahrscheinlich
installiert
sind. Das ist sowas wie H-Top zum Beispiel.
Das kannst du
mittlerweile verwenden, weil ich glaube, wir haben keinen
Server, wo nicht H-Top drauf ist.
Das ist das nächste.
Das dritte ist Tools,
die nicht vorinstalliert sind
und auch wahrscheinlich nicht vorinstalliert sind, die man
aber easy aus den Standard-Repos
aller Distributionen nachinstallieren
kann. Also
im Prinzip auch sowas wie
H-Top, wenn es nicht standardmäßig da installiert
wäre, bei uns auf allen Servern.
So, das sind die drei
Arten von Tools, die ich
ruhigen Gewissens verwenden kann
oder verwende.
Alles andere
verwende ich nur,
wenn ich es
hauptsächlich quasi nur
bei mir auf dem System
brauche. Ja, zum Beispiel
ist H-Top nicht Abandoned.
Ist es das? Weiß ich nicht.
Es funktioniert? Ne, das ist nicht Abandoned.
Das hat doch erst I.O. Geschichten
eingebaut.
Da ist nix Abandoned.
Guck, vier Tage
ago wurde das erst geupdatet.
Da ist nix Abandoned.
Ja, also zum Beispiel
mein Visual Studio Code
oder sowas, das verwende ich. Das brauche ich aber
halt hauptsächlich nur bei mir lokal.
Da ist es egal, ob ich weiß, wie man es auf dem Server bedienen kann oder nicht.
Das gibt es da einfach nicht und wird da auch nicht gebraucht.
So Tools verwende ich dann auch.
Aber was ich beispielsweise nicht verwende ist, zum Beispiel sowas hier.
Ja, diese ganzen, so, Modern Replacement für LS zum Beispiel.
Ich habe mich übrigens vertan, das heißt nicht extra.
Was suche ich, Chat?
Ich suche nicht extra.
ich suche
oder suche ich doch extra.
Okay, was auch immer.
Als Beispiel reicht das ja.
Ja, also irgendwelche
Grab-Ersatz-Tools,
LS-Ersatz-Tools oder sowas.
Das ist ja alles ganz schön und gut,
dass es das kann, aber das ist meistens
nicht hundertprozentig kompatibel dazu
und ich verlerne, wenn ich mich
an die tollen Sachen
gewöhnen, die das kann, wie man normale
Tools verwendet. Das ist dann Zeug, was
ich nicht benutze.
Genauso, was ich auch nicht mehr
mache. Ach,
ESA heißt es jetzt. Das habe ich gesucht.
Genau.
Das da. Das habe ich gesucht.
Ja.
Ja, so was verwende ich da nicht.
Hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Null.
dementsprechend so tue es auch nicht
aber bei extra esa sind die flex eigentlich gleich also bei extra waren die flex nicht
gleich da muss ich ein extra alias für bohr und ich habe das mal eine weile benutzt
aber allein schon dass der output nicht gleich ist das ist mir nichts ich will so daran gewöhnt
sein an den LSLA-Output, dass ich auf dem
Server direkt erkenne, ey, bam,
äh, execute für andere und so.
Ich will das genau so haben.
Okay,
wenn es der gleiche, exakt der gleiche
Output wäre,
mit exakt den gleichen möglichen
Flags,
nur colored,
ordentlich, dann könnte
ich mir das vorstellen, ja.
Also probieren wir doch mal aus, ob das wirklich so ist.
Aber ich hab's sogar installiert.
Hier.
Geht das?
Geht nicht.
Siehst du?
Bam.
Schon
ein Grund, warum ich es nicht verwende.
Mein Standard LS würde damit nicht funktionieren.
Deswegen will ich mich nicht an die Tools gewöhnen.
An diese Extra-Tools.
Das ist halt die Stufe der Sachen, die ich verwende.
Deswegen, so cool diese Sachen sind,
umso
weniger benutze ich sie.
Eine Sache,
die ich jetzt verwende,
ist
Hoyotils.
Ist das hier. Seht ihr das?
Dieses
GetDiff hier,
das ist Delta, genau.
Das verwende ich seit
einer Weile
Das finde ich sehr praktisch
Git-Diffs gucke ich mir zu 90%
eh nur
bei mir lokal an, es ändert nichts an der
Handhabung von Git, es sieht einfach
nur ein bisschen schöner aus
Man braucht
eine lokale Git-Config dafür, aber
wen juckt's, ja? Ich kann
Git-Diff auf dem Server immer noch
noch
lesen und das Beste ist
Delta
ist in den Red Hat Standard-Repos
drin. Das heißt, ich könnte das
einfach, wenn ich jetzt öfters
diffen würde auf Servern
oder auf irgendwelchen Remote-Systemen,
könnte ich einfach GitDelta nachentzählen.
Also das ist ein Tool, das verwende ich dann.
Und Delta finde ich enorm praktisch.
Also ich finde es einfach viel besser
lesbar als
ähm
Wie kann ich denn jetzt mal
einen Vergleich machen?
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Docker run?
Ich starte einfach einen Docker-Container.
XE.
Äh, nee.
13, ne?
Oh, doch, doch.
Äh.
Chat.
Ah, ich hab ein Kernel-Update gemacht.
Deswegen geht mein Docker jetzt nicht.
Na gut, wie dem auch sei.
Normales Git-Diff sieht halt so aus.
So sieht es aus.
Und Exa...
Nicht Exa, wie komm ich da...
Und Delta macht es halt per Hintergrundfarben.
und insgesamt ein bisschen besser lesbar finde ich ja weil es dann halt auch highlight okay
dieser teil hat sich geändert und das also finde ich halt ein bisschen besser lesbar
als rein nackiges nackiges diff so
Also wir haben Git-Repos ausgecheckt auf Servern.
Also ich mache das sogar relativ oft im Notfall.
Der Notfall, der tritt öfters mal ein.
Und zwar, wir haben ein Git-Repo, wo die ganzen YAML-Files, also die ganzen Helm-Value-Files drin liegen.
Und manchmal muss ich irgendwelche Sachen hotfix-mäßig patchen.
Und dann mache ich einen Helm-Install nochmal oben drüber und brauche halt die Value-Files dafür.
Ja, ich weiß, man kann sich die aktuell gesetzten Value-Files auslesen, aber das ist ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt das, was man haben will.
Und dann clone ich mir das Git-Repo mit den Value-Files auf den Server drauf.
Was ich praktisch finde, dass das geht.
Ja, ich könnte es bei mir auch lokal klonen und die YAML-Files rüber SCPen oder sowas.
Das geht natürlich auch.
Aber ab und zu habe ich schon Git-Repos auf Servern.
So, was trennt das denn?
Was soll ich mir angucken?
Div. Nav.
Haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
A Git Div Pager based on Delta, but with FileTree.
Hä?
Aha.
Wie darf ich mir das denn jetzt vorstellen?
Okay
Viel interessanter
Gibt es DivNav unter Redhead
Falls ich sie auf irgendeiner Kiste mal brauche
Okay, gibt's nicht
DivNav
So, okay, und jetzt
Okay, jetzt sage ich
Git log minus p nach DivNav
Und jetzt hängt es.
Wow.
Chat.
Das ist broken.
Ach ne.
Meine Schelle ist kaputt.
Dadurch.
oder muss ich sagen geht
diff ja sowas
hier zum
sowas hier zum Beispiel
und das kann ich jetzt pipen nach
diff nav
ok das funzt
das ist in der Tat
sehr praktisch
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Das gefällt mir.
Und das ist so ein Tool, was ich auch
ruhig benutzen kann,
weil das halt was ist. Das benutzt du nicht auf dem
Server. Das brauchst du da auch nicht.
Das benutzt du nur lokal, um irgendwelche Sachen
zu überprüfen.
Das ist in der Tat echt ganz cool.
Was ich ein bisschen doof finde, ist, dass
Git log minus 1
Minus p
Nicht funzt
Ifnav
Ach doch, funktioniert auch
Aber was nicht funktioniert ist, wenn ich das Ganze
Ja, das ist zu lang, guck mal
Das gesamte Log, das kackt ab
Okay, aber das kann ich auch verstehen
Das kommt da einfach nicht mehr klar
Aber ich kann zum Beispiel an den letzten 50 Comments
Ey, das ist sehr praktisch.
Das ist richtig nice.
Weil gerade hier in dem Output,
wenn man hier den Output,
also man hat jetzt quasi den Diff
der letzten 50 Comets.
Was man oft macht ist,
man sucht hier drinnen danach irgendwas
und dann scrollt man wieder hoch.
Ah, zu welchem Comet
und welche Datei gehört das Ganze?
Dann ist das wirklich praktisch.
Und es ist halt auch mega,
dass hier oben drüber anscheinend
das Comet angezeigt.
Ach ne, hier oben siehst du da das Comet.
Ja, das ist... Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Das ist gut. Das gefällt mir. Das hat was.
Das hat was.
Das ist wirklich ganz cool.
Aber Chat, wisst ihr, was ich nicht checke?
Ich habe jetzt ja die letzten 50 Comets.
Ähm.
Wie? Wie gehe ich denn jetzt einen Comet zurück?
Oder denkt der fälschlicherweise, das ist alles ein Comet?
Ups.
Ich kann F1 doch nicht drücken.
Switch Panel.
Der denkt, es ist alles das gleiche
Comet, oder?
Ja, das ist natürlich doof.
Der denkt, es ist alles das gleiche Comet.
Der soll mir die einzelnen Comets
anstellen.
Dann ist es doch nicht so geil.
Dann bringt mir das ja gar nichts.
Dann sehe ich ja gar nicht, zu welchem Comedy-Änderung
die ich sehe gehört.
Das ist dann schon mal nicht mehr so toll.
Ich lasse es mal drauf.
Vielleicht brauchen wir das in Zukunft nochmal.
Manchmal brauche ich ein bisschen,
bis ich mich an spezielle Tools
gewöhnt habe.
So.
Juckt nicht,
juckt nicht, juckt nicht, juckt nicht.
Okay.
So, da haben wir noch einen GitHub-Trend,
den wir uns angucken müssen, und zwar
Cobot, nee,
C-Sharp.
Ob da irgendwas interessant ist. Das ist meistens sehr unspektakulär und langweilig, was da trendet.
Bitworn-Server. Okay.
Wusste gar nicht, dass der offizielle Bitworn-Server in .NET programmiert ist.
Übrigens, Bitworn hat sich jetzt unbeliebt gemacht.
Die haben ihre... Die haben zwei Sachen gemacht.
Die haben ihre Preise ordentlich erhöht.
Und was war das andere noch?
Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Vor ein paar Tagen
hat sich Reddit self-hosted
über Bitworn aufgeregt.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken. Self-hosted, Bitworn,
Reddit.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal,
warum sie sich aufgeregt haben.
Diese Woche
haben die
die Vault worden verboten.
Ne.
Müssen wir mal kurz gucken.
Hoffen wir mal, dass die Suche
gescheit funktioniert.
Nein, ich will...
Oh Gott.
Reddit! Scheiß Seite,
Alter.
Ich will in diesem Subreddit suchen.
Ihr Bitwarn Heating to eliminate freemium and possible World War support in the near future.
Genau.
Das könnte es gewesen sein.
Und unter
Linux
gab es das auch.
Bitwarden
haben die auch gemaggert.
The Quiet Renovation
at Bitwarden, genau.
Ja.
Die haben irgendwo...
Dinger getrieben, wo sich Reddit drüber aufgeregt hat.
Ich bin immer froh, wenn ich solche Dinger lese, dass ich seit Jahren, man könnte eigentlich schon sagen seit Jahrzehnten, auf Keypass hänge.
da kann einfach nichts passieren rein lokaler passwort save millionenfach benutzt
einfach keepers und ganz im ernst wer seine passwörter bei einem cloud service speichert
dem ist ja nicht mehr zu helfen egal was diese ganzen cloud services sagen von ja wir können
die Dinger selbst nicht lesen,
kleinseitige Verschlüsselung,
ja, das kann, also es gibt ja mehrere Sachen,
ja, man glaubt es ihnen,
und ja, es ist auch aktuell so,
okay, gehen wir einfach mal
von aus, die sagen die Wahrheit, das ist so,
wirklich überprüfen, gescheit
kannst du das ja nicht,
die, ähm,
die Apps
für iOS und Android sind ja bei
Bitwarden, glaube ich, auch Open Source,
das Ding ist nur, kann man
wirklich sicher sagen,
dass die Apps, die auf GitHub liegen, auch wirklich die Apps sind, die in Apps so angeboten werden.
Bin ich mir nicht sicher. Ich tippe mal, kann man nicht.
Und das nächste ist, mit dem nächsten Update kann das alles schon ganz anders aussehen.
Sei es, dass es unbeabsichtigt ist, dass sie irgendwas Security-mäßig verkacken
und die Passwörter nicht mehr encrypted übertragen werden oder irgendwie nicht richtig gespeichert werden,
lokal gecached werden, was auch immer. Oder absichtlich.
Und das kann relativ easy passieren, solche Dinger.
Ich nehme mal eine Sache als Beispiel.
Ich habe eine Zeit lang unter iOS eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-App verwendet.
Die hieß...
Also das aktuell verwende ich EntoAuth.
EntoAuth ist richtig nice.
Ich habe aber der Vorgänger von EntoAuth...
wie hieß das? Revio.
Revio 2FA
oder so hieß das.
Ravio.
Das war eine App, die war
im Prinzip für 2-Faktor-Authentifizierungstokens
gedacht.
Eigentlich ganz cool.
Und von einem Tag auf den anderen Tag
gab es ein Update
mit einer Paywall.
Du konntest
von einem Tag auf den anderen
nach einem Update nicht mehr auf deine
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungstalkens zugreifen.
Und das ist beschissen.
Weil wenn du die nicht noch woanders irgendwo gespeichert hast,
dann kannst du dich jetzt bei vielen Services nicht mehr einloggen.
Ich bin eh der Meinung, viele Leute unterschätzen die Gefahr,
die von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung...
Also Gefahr ist vielleicht ein übertrieben,
aber das Risiko, das von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungs-Apps ausgeht,
Es ist im Prinzip das gleiche, wie wenn du Passwörter verlierst.
Ja, dein zweiter Faktor ist zwingend notwendig, um dich einzuloggen bei einem Service.
Das heißt, wenn du deinen Zwei-Faktor-Token Shared Secret verlierst, ist der Zugang zumindest deutlich erschwert.
Ja, es gibt noch Backup-Codes, man kann es vielleicht irgendwie über fünf Ecken recoveren, aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich, deutlich erschwert, ja, das Login.
und man muss seine zwei faktor authentifizieren auf jeden fall irgendwie backup und hast im
zweifelsfall gelitten also ich benutze jetzt ente auf und machte halt backup mit finde ich
finde ich übrigens kann ich übrigens wie ios hat ich glaube es gibt es auch gibt es auch für android
ich benutze hier ente off finde ich sehr nice ist auch komplett open source auf github weil
auch für die frage weißt du wirklich ob es das gleiche ist was im github ist was im app store
ist. So, ach ja, und die
Frage, warum ich, das ist das
eine sehr gute Frage.
Äh, wo ist sie denn?
Warum machst du das nicht auch in
KeyPass? Naja, weil
der Sinn von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
ja ist, dass du einen zweiten, unabhängigen
Faktor hast.
Wenn ich den
zweiten Faktor mit meinem
Passwort zusammenspeichere,
heißt das auch,
wenn einer Zugriff auf mein Passwort-Safe
bekommt hat er automatisch zugriff auch auf die zwei auf den zweiten faktor
womit kein zweiter faktor mehr ist
deswegen ist es ziemlich bescheuert ehrlich gesagt seine zwei faktor
geschichte auch im gleichen passwort safe zu speichern wie seine passwörter
da kann man sich das ganze auch schenken also macht keinen sinn
Deswegen benutze ich Enter Orth und mache da regelmäßig Backup.
Was man machen kann ist, was natürlich geht, was geht, wenn man unbedingt Key Pass verwenden will,
man kann ein zweites Key Pass machen, nur für zwei Faktor Tokens.
Das wird natürlich funktionieren.
Wobei ich es ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen
fragwürdig finde, es auf dem gleichen Rechner
zu haben und nacheinander
zu entlocken und so. Das finde ich
irgendwie
widerspricht dem Sinn von Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ja, genau.
Sehe ich auch so. Also das finde ich
irgendwie relativ
am Schutz,
dass es bietet, vorbei.
Ja, deswegen habe ich
EnterAuth auf dem Handy.
Ich habe Backups davon.
Aber
insgesamt bin ich mit der Kombi
eigentlich ganz glücklich.
Ja,
wir kriegen jetzt YubiKeys auf der Arbeit.
Was ich sehr praktisch finde.
Da drückst du einfach nur noch drauf
und kannst dich per SSH auf
Servern einloggen. Also du machst
SSH auf den Server,
dann kriegst du einen Prompt, dann drückst du auf deinem
Yubi-Key auf den Knopf
und dann wirst du eingeloggt, eigentlich ziemlich nice
die Idee
ich hab das schon gesehen
so eine Demo davon, aber
wir haben selbst noch keine Yubi-Keys gekriegt, aber
so wird das in Zukunft dann laufen, das finde ich
sehr praktisch
Ravi Authenticator nach dem
letzten Update kaputt, ach ja
und um diese Story jetzt hier nochmal
zu beenden.
Ich musste damals,
um auf meine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
Sachen wieder zugreifen zu können,
musste ich ein
Downgrade machen von der App.
Chat, mal eine Frage an euch.
Hat jemand von euch schon mal
ein Downgrade von der App
unter iOS gemacht?
Das geht.
Ja.
Aber wie, Alter?
Das ist wirklich die beschissenste Sache ever.
Mal gucken, ob hier noch eine Anleitung drin ist.
Lass mal gucken, ob es eine...
Die haben ihre GitHub-Issues-Seite gelöscht.
Lul.
Ja, warum wohl, ne?
Clean up.
Ja, ja.
Das geht.
Ja.
Hier ist die Anleitung.
Wie das funktioniert.
Also.
Also es ist wirklich abenteuerlich.
Aber ich habe es gemacht.
Das hat funktioniert.
Zu One Passwort wechseln?
Wer macht denn sowas freiwillig?
Also, es funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Du brauchst iTunes 12.6.5 unter Windows.
Weißt du, ich habe mir damals eine Windows 4 M mit iTunes installiert.
So.
Dann brauchst du einen Man-in-the-Middle-Proxy.
Und eine Apple-ID.
So.
Du musst...
Also das ist wirklich super kompliziert.
Du musst die Unique-App-ID von dieser Version raussuchen, die du installieren willst.
Das geht hier irgendwie über IPA-Archive.
Also du brauchst die Unique-ID deiner App in der richtigen Version, die du haben willst.
Wir brauchen keinen Jailbreak.
Genau, Product Contents.
So, dann musst du
einen Man in the Middle Proxy installieren.
Irgendwelche Zertifikatsmagic mit dem Proxy machen.
Einen Breakpoint setzen bei einem passenden Request.
In dem Request.
Ne genau, man muss die App anklicken zum installieren.
Dann.
Den Breakpoint einschalten.
In den Request reingucken.
aus dem Request
sich irgendwie die
JSON Payload
by Product angucken
und dann
daraus
irgendwas extrahieren
dann kannst
so genau und dann kannst du in diesem Request
die
App Version
replacen.
Also quasi, du änderst den
Request, der von deinem Gerät an den App Store geht.
Und der requestet dann quasi
eine alte Version damit.
Und dann
bekommst du
das passende IPA. Das ist die
iOS-Anwendung.
Und dann musst du
dieses IPA noch
über iTunes installieren.
Und dann hast du downgradet.
Easy, oder?
Dazu kann man eigentlich nur sagen,
das ist super.
Also cringe, wer das nicht kann.
Die Frage ist eher,
wie der Dude da drauf kommt.
Das ist in der Tat die richtige Frage, ja?
Wie kommt denn du drauf?
Sehr gute Frage.
Das habe ich mich auch gefragt damals.
Wie kommt der da drauf?
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Und das musste ich damals machen,
dass ich wieder Zugriff auf meine 2FA-Tokens bekommen habe.
Ist halt schon, ne?
Deswegen, du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen, was irgendwelche Anbieter sagen.
Morgen kann die App kaputt sein.
Ihr steht da.
Und guckt doof aus der Wäsche.
So, gut.
hätten wir github trends abgehakt also dort net blub blub blub was für ein ding
sub subtitle opti scala was zum teufel ist opti scala clean ag für alle die
die gerne 30 Milliarden Ordner und Interfaces haben wollen.
Osu!
Ah ja, ja.
Vinslopper.
Das sollte Vindislopper heißen.
Optiscaler.
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, was Optiscaler ist.
Games Launcher?
Oder was?
Oder wie?
Was ist denn OptiScaler überhaupt?
Upscaling.
OptiScaler bridges
Upscaling FrameGen across GPUs.
Also irgendeine Upscaling
KI oder was?
auch immer ist ein tool der letztes juli plays upscalers in games okay was für
frame generation und upscaling klingt klingt very high iq
So sieht's aus.
Okay.
Chat.
Schauen wir doch mal.
Wieso ist der Windows Desktop so leer?
Weil es neu installiert wurde
Vor ein paar Monaten
So, schauen wir doch mal
Ich wollte mir unbedingt dieses Video hier angucken
Äh
Das da
By the way, fragt mich nicht, warum
Google das wieder übersetzt, ja
Das ist ein deutsches Video
aber der Titel wird, ähm, oder ist der Titel wirklich so?
Nee, oder?
Guck, guck mal hier.
Das, das übersetzt doch.
Wie ist das, wie ist denn der echte Titel von diesem Fuck, wie, oh Mann, YouTube, Mann.
Egal, wir gucken das trotzdem.
Ähm, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt heute.
Und wir haben es sogar nachstellen können.
Wir haben es eben nachgestellt.
Guck mal.
Chrome.
Ich muss diesen hässlichen Keyring irgendwie...
Ja, ja.
Guck.
Wir konnten sogar nachstellen.
mit die Bahn sperrt Linux-User aus.
Hier, seht ihr?
Aber witzigerweise nur in Chrome, nicht in Firefox.
Ach ja, jetzt auch in Firefox.
Okay, in Firefox wohl
nicht so oft.
Guck, aber Chrome wird ausgesperrt.
Chrome wird immer ausgesperrt.
Firefox nicht.
Cringe von der Bahn, ey.
Pff.
So, das wollte ich mir angucken, weil was gibt's besseres, als jetzt erstmal eine Stunde über Windows 11 flamen.
Guck mal hier, so endete neulich eine Windows 11.
Eine Windows 11 Installation, die endet in der Regel mit, ähm, nein, nein, nein, only basic, only basic, only basic, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, basic.
Muss den ganzen Shit wegklicken.
Neue Installation bei mir.
Helfen Sie uns, die Roboter zu schlagen.
Was?
Ist das irgendeine dumme Übersetzung von...
Help us to beat the bots?
Oder irgendwie sowas? Könnte es sein?
Also die haben Bots quasi übersetzt mit Roboter.
Wobei Bots ja ein für sich stehender Begriff irgendwie ist
Und jetzt helfen sie uns die Roboter zu schlagen
Ja und das war's, da ging es nicht weiter
Ich vermute, dass da so eine Captcha-Abfrage sein sollte
Aber offenbar hat Microsoft die vergessen einzubauen
Was doof ist
Geil
Bisschen zu viel gevibecoded wieder, würde ich sagen, oder?
Das ist so schlimm mittlerweile.
Das ist so kaputt einfach nur.
... weil ich Windows nicht weiter installieren konnte.
Und das ist nur ein Beispiel dafür, wie doll kaputt Windows 11 ist.
Also so kaputt, dass Microsoft inzwischen mehrfach öffentlich zugegeben hat,
dass es da wohl Probleme mit der Produktqualität gibt.
Sogar von CEO Satya Nadella höchstpersönlich.
Das sagt Microsoft. Hier in diesem Video gibt es jetzt den Realitätscheck.
Also die Praxis. Was genau bekommt man, wenn man aktuell Windows 11 installiert?
Was man bekommt? Ganz viel AI-Slob und Copilot an allen Ecken.
Auf einem Copilot-plus-fähigen Rechner, also mit NPU, mit Neural Processing Unit, also mit freigeschalteten KI-Funktionen.
Ist das wirklich alles?
By the way, was ich ja auch sehr, sehr weird, Champ, finde, ist,
dass man jetzt das Notepad hier oben so was anzeigt,
what's new, und wenn du das anklickst,
möchte sich Notepad, dass du dich einloggst.
Notepad, Alter. Einloggen. Notepad.
Das ist so unglaublich dämlich, Alter.
Einloggen, um Notepad zu verwenden.
Am Arsch einloggen, ja.
Microsoft öffentlich zu Kreuze kriechen muss. Spoiler? Nein. Viel schlimmer.
Und das ist jetzt kein Bait, sondern ich war wirklich, wirklich ernsthaft geschockt. Bleib dran.
Monkels.
War da nicht was mit Markdown-Exploit in Notepad?
Ja, du konntest den Notepad, glaube ich, Dateien verlinken und die wurden dann irgendwie geöffnet, obwohl sie nicht geöffnet werden sollen oder sowas.
Was ist besser, Windows oder macOS?
Naja, ich bin kein macOS User, muss ich gleich dazu sagen.
Aber das Schöne an macOS ist, dass macOS Unix basic genug ist, um dir weniger auf den Sack zu gehen wie Windows.
Wenn du Windows allerdings benutzt, um da Windows Sachen drauf zu machen,
also zum Beispiel Spiele mit Anti-Cheat spielen und sowas,
Ja, dann wird der macOS auch nichts bringen. Ansonsten würde ich aber macOS, dadurch dass du dir das relativ nervfrei einstellen kannst und du kannst ja da auch gefühlt so eh alles mit Homebrew und sonst was nachinstallieren, was du so brauchst, würde ich auf jeden Fall macOS Windows vorziehen.
Ja, wenn euch die oft halbgaren Co-Pilot-KI-Funktionen in Windows 11 nicht reichen, dann ist vielleicht Mammuth was für euch.
Die sponsern dieses Video.
Für 11,90 Euro im Monat bekommt ihr hier Zugriff auf GPT, Cloud, Mistral, Gemini, DeepSeek, Perplexity sowie Flux und Nano-Banana für die Bildgenerierung.
Nano-Banana.
Die neuesten Versionen werden direkt nach Veröffentlichung aktualisiert.
Ja, und der Preis ist echt ziemlich gut, wenn man bedenkt, dass alleine ChatGPT Plus über das doppelte im Monat kostet.
Mit Mammuth könnt ihr obendrein antworten, per Reprompting vergleichen, Dokumente und Bilder analysieren, personalisierte Projekte erstellen oder mit.
Haben die auch API-Access?
Der Sprach-KI.
Dass man damit Open Code oder so verwenden kann?
Mammuth ist ein europäisches Unternehmen mit strenger Datenschutz-Policy.
Alles im Starter-Paket ab 11,90 Euro inklusive Mehrwertsteuer für Privatkunden.
By the way, wisst ihr, was ich mittlerweile richtig gut finde?
Duck AI.
Weil die haben
Cloud Heiko 4.5 drin.
Und das ist echt ganz okay.
Kannst zum Beispiel fragen,
wer ist der
beste, was fragen wir mal,
deutsche Let's Play
Streamer, keine Ahnung,
kommt wahrscheinlich Conk oder so raus.
Und
ja, das dachte ich mir, dass
das was in der Richtung rauskommt.
Ähm, ja,
das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Kostet nichts.
Und es ist
private.
Ja.
Eigentlich richtig nice.
Also duck.ai
für anonyme
KI-Stells
mit auch einem ganz guten Model.
Reasoning. Okay.
Erkläre mir das
Twitch-Emote
kek
w besonders
ausführlich. Mindestens
2000 Worte.
Mal gucken, was da rauskommt.
Okay, 2000 Worte ist gar nicht so viel
Aber ich habe ja auch gesagt
Mindestens 2000 Worte
Bam, guck, jetzt kriegst du eine
Super krasse Erklärung
Was keck W eigentlich für
Ein tolles Emote ist
Es hört auch nicht auf
Und das alles kostenlos, kannst du nicht beschweren
Also wirklich, Duck AI
plus OpenCode
für
Command-Line-Sachen.
Also ich meine jetzt nicht beides zusammen,
sondern hier im Browser und das andere
im
Terminal.
Das ist echt eine gute Kombination.
Eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Nach dem Seefährtchen-Emoji, ja, das es nicht gibt, ne?
Gibt es ein Seefährtchen-Emoji?
Ja, es gibt ein Seefährtchen-Emoji.
Äh...
Das ist ein Seepferdchen?
Du bist ein Noob.
Das gibt es gar nicht.
Lul weh.
Immerhin ist es einsichtig.
Nun gut.
Weiter.
Gucken wir uns mal das Video an.
und flamen ein wenig über Windows 11.
Wenn ihr das interessant findet, schaut mal in die Beschreibung.
Da findet ihr mehr Infos und einen Link zum Mammut.
Werbung Ende.
Okay, zuerst mal ein kleiner Disclaimer.
Das Video hier soll kein dumpfes Microsoft-Bashing sein.
Wirklich nicht.
Seit ich ungefähr 14 bin, benutze ich...
Es ist ein Microsoft-Bashing, zu Recht.
Ich selbst Windows.
Und ich habe Windows deshalb auch irgendwie ins Herz geschlossen.
Meine Liebe erkaltet allerdings immer mehr, weil...
Ich muss kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Die ist so brutal warm gerade drin.
26,7 Grad.
Ich schwitze mir einen ab.
Klimaanlage.
So, passt.
Weiter.
... sich Windows mehr und mehr in eine Richtung entwickelt,
die immer weniger mit dem zu tun hat, was ich von einem Betriebssystem will.
Deshalb benutze ich inzwischen immer mehr Linux und macOS.
Und jetzt wollte ich mir für dieses Video nochmal im Detail angucken, was man eigentlich so erlebt, wenn man aktuell Windows 11 installiert.
Mein Versuchsaufbau, ein Rechner mit AMD Ryzen 9, AI Max Plus 395, also mit einem extra KI-Chip, der 50 Billionen Operationen pro Sekundenschaft, abgekürzt TOPS, also Trillion Operations Per Second.
Und darauf die neueste Windows 11 ISO mit Version 25H2 drauf.
Los geht's mit Kapitel 1, Installation.
Ja, hier poppt direkt so eine Bildershow auf oder Diashow, wie Windows das nennt,
wo man dann sehen kann, was man alles Tolles jetzt mit KI machen kann.
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen. Wir haben doch erst vor, weiß ich, vor...
Vor einer Woche oder so haben wir doch erst Windows 11 installiert.
Da gab es das doch nicht, oder bin ich jetzt blöd?
Und ja, dann steht da, ergreifen Sie Maßnahmen zu allem, was Sie sehen.
Aktion per Mal.
Toll, toll übersetzt.
Ausklick hebt Text und Bilder hervor, bei denen Sie Hintergründe weichzeichnen, Objekte löschen, nach Informationen suchen und mehr tun können.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ob das ein Problem in meiner persönlichen Informationsverarbeitung ist, aber ich habe das dreimal gelesen.
Ich verstehe das wirklich nicht.
Das habe ich geskippt, achso.
Aber wir sind ja hier noch bei der Installation.
Willkommen noch zu der Funktion.
Könnt ihr euch schon mal darauf freuen.
Super Funktion.
Heißt allerdings in echt anders.
So, als nächstes steht da, schalten Sie Ihre Microsoft-Erfahrung frei.
Ja, das haben wir auch geskippt.
Da wird mir jetzt also angepriesen, was ich alles kriege, wenn ich mich hier anmelde.
Ja gut, das klingt ja freiwillig. Kann ich mich denn jetzt trotzdem entscheiden, dass ich mich da lieber nicht anmelden will?
Natürlich nicht. Habt ihr euch wahrscheinlich schon gedacht.
Aber nur bei Windows 11 Pro geht es ja, wenn du sagst, ich will ein School-or-Work-Account einer Domäne beitreten und dann einfach nie einer Domäne beitreten.
beitritt beitritt nicht das ging früher mal geht jetzt nicht mehr also zumindest nicht offiziell
bei der konkurrenz also bei mac os und natürlich auch bei linux ist das kein problem die kann man
problemlos installieren ohne das hat allein schon wichtig für den arsch bei linux gibt gar keinen
account ja bei windows 11 muss man in sein microsoft account es gibt ein workaround man
Man kann mit Shift F10 auf die Konsole und dann kann man da Start MS-CXH.
Oh, das ist was Neues. Das kenne ich noch nicht.
Da darf man lokalen Nutzer anlegen. Da geht es ohne Account.
Warum ist denn die? Das wirkt jetzt aber nicht so wie 4K gerade.
Aber auch wenn ich Betriebssysteme eigentlich gerne mit lokalem Konto betreibe,
habe ich das jetzt hier nicht gemacht.
Ich werde mich jetzt hier also in meinen Microsoft Account anmelden,
weil ich will ja den offiziellen Zustand mir angucken.
Also anmelden, übrigens mit einem ganz normalen privaten Microsoft-Konto von mir, nicht mit irgendeinem beruflichen Konto, wo womöglich vom Arbeitgeber irgendwelche Sachen eingestellt sind.
Also alles ganz normal, persönlich, privat von mir angelegtes Microsoft-Konto.
Ich gebe also meine Mailadresse ein und dann kommt da, anmelden mit einem Hauptschlüssel.
Stecken Sie den Sicherheitsschlüssel.
Ja genau, und dann denkst du dir, hä, was?
Das hatte ich auch. Ich wollte mich letztens seit Jahren mal wieder an meinem Xbox-Account anmelden.
und das habe ich sogar auf
Moment, ich habe das sogar auf Twitter gepostet
Ne, bei Katzis
habe ich manchmal auch noch was anderes gepostet
Ja
ich sollte mich auch mit irgendeinem komischen
Schlüssel anmelden
dann hab ich auch weiter gedrückt und dann kam das
und
ich konnte mich nicht mehr einloggen
ich hab dann einen anderen Browser gestartet
damit ging es dann witzigerweise
aber das sind halt so Dinge
das ist halt irgendein Vibe-Codeder-Shit
von Microsoft
das sind halt
mittlerweile Failend-Orden, guckt auch mal auf
GitHub, die sind wirklich die
Die Basic-Sachen, die halt einfach ohne Diskussion funktionieren müssen, funktionieren nicht mehr.
In den USB-Anschluss. Hä? Hauptschlüssel, Sicherheitsschlüssel, was?
Ich kann wirklich mit Sicherheit sagen, dass ich kein USB-Gerät besitze, was ich hier jetzt verwenden könnte.
Vermutlich ist sowas wie ein Fido 2-Key gemeint. Besitze ich nicht.
Ich habe auch zuerst überhaupt nicht verstanden, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Aber dann habe ich mir das selbst so erschlossen. Offenbar habe ich mich mal auf macOS in diesen Microsoft Account eingeloggt und dann ein Passkey erstellt, der dann in meiner macOS Keychain, also in der Cloud gespeichert wurde.
Aber warum sagt Windows das nicht?
Ja und warum kann ich nicht was anderes auswählen?
... die nicht mal den Begriff Passkey sind. Ja, und ich habe mir das herleiten können. Ich mache aber auch hauptberuflich Dinge mit Computern. Die meisten Windows-Nutzer hätten das vermutlich nicht verstanden. Also kein Passkey für mich, muss ich mich also anders einloggen. Ich gebe also mein Passwort ein und werde dann aufgefordert, mich mit einem zweiten Faktor auszuweisen. Ich wähle da jetzt SMS auf meinem Handy aus und dann kommt, helfen Sie uns, die Roboter zu schlagen.
Mehr nicht. Ich habe das mehrfach ausprobiert, bin mehrfach zurückgegangen und wieder hin.
Und ja, der Rechner hatte auch eine Internetverbindung.
Hier habe ich mir auch wieder selbst hergeleitet, dass hier in dem Kontext wohl so ein Captcha erscheinen sollte.
Also, kennt ihr ja diese Tests, ne?
Da wurde zu hart Vibe-coded wieder.
... Fahrräder oder Autos erkennen soll, um Bots abzuwehren.
Also, Captcha, completely automated public Turing test to tell computers and humans apart.
Dafür steht Captcha!
Das ist mir auch neu, das wusste ich nicht.
Wenn ihr jetzt sagt, ja Keno, das war hier ja aber ganz spezifisch dein System, da war vielleicht ganz speziell was komisch.
Nein, zu beiden Problemen, also diesem Parsky-Ding und dieser Roboter-Schlagen-Geschichte,
da findet man im Netz etliche Stellen, in denen Leute genau das gleiche Problem schildern.
Also ich bin definitiv nicht der Einzige, der dieses Problem hat.
Fassen wir mal zusammen, schon beim Installieren passieren bei Windows 11 richtig krasse Fails.
Also Fails, die bei vielen Leuten dazu führen, dass sie nicht weiter installieren können.
Und ja, das ist eine manuelle Neuinstallation.
Da könnt ihr jetzt sagen, das passiert nur bei Leuten, die sich mit Computern auskennen, weil sonst machen ja keine Leute eine eigene Neuinstallation.
Normale Leute kaufen sich ja Rechner, bei denen Windows vorinstalliert ist.
Aber beide meiner Fails sind ja nicht beim Installieren spezifisch passiert, sondern die sind beim Einloggen passiert.
Das heißt, das hätte mir auch passieren können, wenn ich einen neuen Rechner gekauft hätte und versucht hätte, mich in meinen vorhandenen Microsoft-Account einzuloggen.
Dann wären diese Probleme sehr wahrscheinlich auch aufgetaucht.
Also der mit dem Passkey ziemlich sicher.
Also das finde ich auf jeden Fall ziemlich heftig, dass schon solche rudimentären Dinge wie Einloggen nicht funktionieren.
Ja, das stimmt.
Also man kann hier auch schon mal sagen, dass Microsoft vielleicht auch bei der deutschen Lokalisierung nicht nur KI ranlassen sollte,
sondern vielleicht auch mal einen Menschen, der die Sprache kann, drüber gucken lassen sollte.
Weil diese schlechten Übersetzungen, dass da nicht einmal Passkeys steht,
dass da irgendwas von Robotern abwerden steht,
also diese schlechten Übersetzungen, die dazu führen, dass man Dinge nicht versteht,
die ziehen sich durch ganz Windows und durchs ganze Video.
Beim dritten Einlog-Versuch hat es auf jeden Fall geklappt.
Als ich als zweiten Faktor E-Mail ausgewählt hatte,
naja, dann geht die Installation auf jeden Fall weiter.
Aber ruhiger bin ich dann trotzdem nicht geworden,
Denn da kommt dann jetzt so viel Werbung.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Das habe ich auch schon öfters wegklicken müssen.
Ach nee, das kenne ich noch gar nicht.
Game Pass Premium, was?
Achso, das ist nur, weil du dich eingeloggt hast mit deinem Microsoft-Account.
Achso.
... sich fast vor wie auf so einer Kaffeefahrt.
Nein, ich will kein OneDrive.
Nein, ich will kein Office 365.
Nein, kein Xbox-Abo.
Nein, nein, nein.
Also, Installation, hm, nicht so gut gelaufen.
Aber jetzt ist ja alles fertig installiert, jetzt kommt Teil 2, Usability.
Und ja, alles, was ich im Bereich Usability schon vor anderthalb Jahren in einem 3003-Video über Windows 11 kritisiert habe,
das ist da immer noch da, das ist immer noch nicht behoben.
Das ist alles immer noch total nervig.
So zum Beispiel diese super verwirrenden doppelten Einstellungsdialoge.
Wenn ich die Energiesparfunktionen einstellen will...
Ja gut, das habe ich ja auch schon oft gezeigt.
Wie gesagt, mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür, ich kann es nicht oft genug zeigen,
wo du wirklich alle Windows-Generationen durchsiehst, ist
Properties, Customize, Change Icon.
Und dann hast du hier so super, super Windows 3.11 Hi-Res Icons.
Aber allein schon dieser Dialog und das hier oben, Alter.
WTF?
die gehen ins gleiche menü aber das erste energiesparplan geht ins alte control panel
ist ein anderes menü die widersprechen sich auch also hier habe ich jetzt mal beste leistung
eingestellt und hier habe ich ausbalanciert eingestellt und welches von den beiden aktiv
keine ahnung und natürlich der klassiker ich kann hier in den einstellungen den dunklen modus für
alles aktivieren aber nicht für den also genau das ist halt einfach nur kompletter bullshitter
mittlerweile und microsoft hat es jetzt auch nicht die letzten jahre besser gemacht die haben nur
kraft rum vibe coded und du hast jetzt ein login button in notepad der genannte energiesparplan
und auch so sachen wie der gerätemanager und die computerverwaltung die halten sich alle nicht an
den daten und das startmenü ins react weil das uralte menü sind die windows seit jahrzehnten
mit sich rumschleppt und ja das ist alles nicht so richtig vertrauens erwecken nicht nur dass diese
menüs so komisch aussehen sondern auch dass sie einfach den systemübergreifenden dank nicht
unterstützt das ist aber zumindest eine der sachen mit dem dark mode bei der microsoft verbesserungen
angekündigt hat wir gucken uns gleich noch mal an ob das bei der aktuell erhältlichen windows
11 beta schon besser geworden ist und schon gepatcht ist ein anderer nerv klassik hat der
Wie kann man nur so scheiße sein? Ja, das frage ich mich bei Windows öfters.
Vor allem ist es ja nicht so, dass da drei Entwickler oder so dran sitzen.
Da sitzen wahrscheinlich hunderte Leute dran und Vibe-Coden den ganzen Tag.
Hier in der normalen Standard-Windows-11-Version noch drin ist, man kann die Position der Taskleiste nicht verändern.
Und das wurde auch seit...
By the way, dieses dumme Wetterding da unten.
Das erste, was ich immer ausblenden muss.
Tag 1, seit Windows 11 existiert, kritisiert.
Hier hat Windows jetzt auch angekündigt, dass das besser werden soll.
Also, dass man die Taskleiste rechts, links, oben, unten drapieren kann.
Und ein anderer Klassiker...
Aber Hauptsache, der Typ hat damals halb geheult bei der Windows 11 Ankündigung, wie geil das ist.
Ihr erinnert euch noch, hoffe ich.
Ich will euch jetzt nicht quälen damit.
... auch seit Tag 1 kritisiert.
Und da hat Microsoft meines Wissens noch nicht angekündigt,
dass sie das verbessern werden,
das komische doppelte Rechtsklick.
Ey, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Dass sich da irgendjemand bei Microsoft gedacht hat,
oh ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Was obendrein auch noch nervig langsam ist.
Guck mal, wie lange das hier dauert.
Du willst sehen?
Okay, für alle, die es nicht kennen.
Aber nur kurz, weil ich habe das schon ein paar Mal gezeigt.
Ähm...
YouTube.
Windows 11. Wir machen das ganz kurz.
Presentation Video.
Hier, guckt. Haben wir doch schon.
Haben wir doch schon angeguckt.
Guck hier.
Wir gucken uns den Anfang an.
Also das ist die Windows 11 Presentation.
Hier.
Pass mal auf.
Also mal davon abgesehen, dass der schon fast am Heulen ist, wenn es losgeht, ja?
Oh, der heult schon fast!
Ich weine auch, wenn ich Windows 11 benutzen muss, ja.
... der nächsten Generation von Windows.
Weißt du, eine große Teilnahme des Befindens des Zukunfts
ist immer die Verständnis des Vergangenen,
besonders in der Produktion.
Und wenn du es dir vorstellst,
hat Windows für 35 Jahre Teil unserer Leben.
30? Das ist unglaublich, oder?
35 Jahre.
Es war eine führige Kraft für...
besser das kann ich euch gleich schon sagen es wird es wird es wird nicht besser vor allem wenn
er dann noch erzählt wieder damals mit seinen eltern die nicht mehr leben irgendwie windows
benutzt dann so ganz ganz schlimm ganz schlimm grausam ok komm das video weiter
und das ist ein wochen überstehen geblieben dauert mit klicken angekündigt dass sie das
verbessern werden das komische doppelte rechtsklick was obendrein auch noch nervig langsam ist guck
mal wie lange das hier dauert mindestens eine halbe sekunde und das ist ein gerade aufgesetztes
dem auf schnelle hardware das wird also potenziell eher schlimmer mit mehr nutzung aber halt am
aller nervigsten es gibt dieses abgespeckte rechtsklick menü und dann gibt es ein vollständiges
und will man das vollständige muss man hier auf weitere optionen anzeigen klicken das ist halt
richtig dumm. Ja.
Das Vollständige. Zum Beispiel hier
bei mir mit den ganzen praktischen... Das ist so
dumm.
Die hatten übrigens eine ganze Weile hier oben auch
nicht stehen, was diese Buttons machen.
Du hattest eine ganze
Weile hier einfach nur diese Icons
und musstest dir dann an der Icons erkennen,
was damit gemeint ist.
Seven-Zip-Aktionen, die ich
echt häufiger benutze, die gibt es dann halt
erst im zweiten Menü. Nervig.
Und jetzt aber der dritte Bereich, nämlich KI.
Co-Pilot, Co-Pilot, Co-Pilot.
Da fokussiert Microsoft ja schon seit einiger Zeit drauf.
Es gibt ja auch seit zwei Jahren die sogenannten Co-Pilot Plus PCs,
die nicht nur eine eigene Co-Pilot-Taste auf der Tastatur haben,
sondern auch dolle neue KI-Sachen können sollen.
Ja, und für diese PCs hat Microsoft strenge Vorgaben,
unter anderem eine NPU, also keine MPU, sondern eine NPU,
Neural Processing Unit, also den KI-Spezialchip.
Und mein Rechner, auf dem Windows 11 läuft, der hat ja so eine NPU.
Da sollten die ganzen Zusatzfunktionen also freigeschaltet sein.
Ja, sollten.
Denn bei meinem AI Max Plus 395 wird die NPU zwar hier im Task Manager angezeigt,
aber ja, die wahrscheinlich zentralste Copilot Plus Funktion und auch die umstrittenste,
die kann ich trotzdem nicht benutzen.
Die Rede ist von Windows Recall, also...
Abruf.
Die haben tatsächlich ihr Produkt übersetzt.
Das ist wie wenn Word auf einmal im Deutsch Wort heißen würde.
Also dieser Funktion, die permanent Screenshots macht von allem, was auf dem Bildschirm ist
und das Ganze dann im Nachhinein durch eine KI-Erkennung durchsuchbar macht.
Ja, also viele Menschen wollten das nicht, weil intim.
Aber wenn man es wollen würde, dann geht es trotzdem nicht.
Das hier sind die Systemanforderungen für Recall.
Co-Pilot plus PC, NPU mit mindestens 40 Tops, ich habe 50.
16 GB RAM habe ich auch locker, 256 GB Speicherkapazität habe ich auch.
Und dann 50 GB freien Speicherplatz habe ich auch.
Benutzer müssen die Geräteverschlüsselung oder Bitlocker aktivieren, habe ich auch.
Jetzt kommt es, Benutzer müssen sich bei Windows Hello erweiterten, grammatikalisch schwierig.
Windows Hello erweiterten Anmeldesicherheit. Was?
Erweiterten Anmeldesicherheit mit mindestens einer aktivierten biometrischen Anmeldeoption registrieren, um sich zu authentifizieren.
Ja, und ich habe mir sogar extra eine Windows Hello kompatible Webcam besorgt und einen Hello kompatiblen Fingerabdrucksensor.
Aber beides ist leider nicht mit ESS, also Enhanced Sign-In Security kompatibel.
Weil in Deutschland gibt es, also Stand Ende Mai, gibt es keine Geräte zu kaufen, die das beherrschen.
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall doll danach gesucht, ich habe keine gefunden.
Und ja, jetzt sagt Microsoft wahrscheinlich, ja Mensch, ihr habt doch alle immer gemeckert,
ihr Journalisten, als wir die Recall-Funktion gezeigt haben, dass das alles so unsicher ist.
Und jetzt meckert ihr, weil es zu sicher ist oder was?
Nein, ich meckere nicht.
Ich fand es einfach nur interessant, dass man die Funktion einfach de facto auf dem stationären PC in Deutschland nicht verwenden kann.
Es gibt natürlich Notebooks, die haben ESS-kompatible biometrische Sensoren drin.
Alles gut, die können dann Recall, aber eben keine Desktops.
Interessant.
Dafür gehen ja die ganzen anderen KI-Funktionen, oder?
Oder? Oder?
Ja, aber nee.
Und das sind halt auch nicht so richtig viele.
Also kommen wir mal zu dem, bei der...
Außer das jetzt alles Copilot heißt.
...Installation beworbenen Aktionen per Maus...
Ergreifen Sie... Ich muss das mal kurz lesen.
Also, ergreifen Sie Maßnahmen zu allem, was Sie sehen.
Hä?
Das ist ja... Das ist ja...
Das ist ja noch schlimmer als die Übersetzung früher von Microsoft.
oft.
Die war ja auch schon immer grausam.
Aber das ist
jetzt, äh.
Mausklick oder besser
Click-to-do. So heißt das auch
offiziell, also Click-to-do. Und das heißt
auch manchmal so in der deutschen Dokumentation.
Klick und los. Da steht dann oben, Aktion per
Mausklick und im Text steht dann öfter mal
Click-to-do. Also, das ist wirklich
nicht gut übersetzt und so übersetzt das ist super verwirrend ist also man kann wohl davon
ausgehen dass es einfach alles mit einer ki übersetzt wurde würde ich sagen und dann nur
noch so halb drüber geguckt auf der 365 website steht auch büro installieren
klick zu du und die funktion hatte ich ja am anfang vorgelesen die beschreibung davon
Klick zu do.
Und die Funktion hatte ich ja am Anfang vorgelesen, die Beschreibung davon, wo ich es nicht ganz verstanden habe, die habe ich jetzt verstanden und die ist einfach total unspektakulär.
Also man kann damit einfach einen Screenshot machen und dann kann man Texte daraus copy-pasten.
Also Windows lässt da eine OCR drüber laufen, lokal auf der NPO, cool, und dann kann man Texte copy-pasten.
Ja, aber das ist halt eine Funktion, die zum Beispiel Handys schon lange können.
Ewig, ja.
Also bei iOS ist diese Texterkennung in Bildern im System integriert.
Bei Android geht das einfach über Google Lens.
Also das ist ja wirklich absolut nichts Spektakuläres.
Eine andere Funktion, die eigentlich ziemlich praktisch sein könnte, sind die live übersetzten Untertitel.
Man hat also eine beliebige Tonquelle, also ein Podcast oder ein Video und kann sich die Sprachspur dann nicht nur transkribieren lassen, sondern auch direkt übersetzen.
Warum ist das so ein riesen, riesen Ding quer übers Video?
Habe ich ja ausprobiert. Japanischsprachiges Video wird direkt übersetzt. Okay, cool.
Aber das kann YouTube doch selber auch.
Läuft auch lokal auf der NPU. Aber erstens geht das nur auf Englisch.
Also man kann sich nur andere Sprachen ins Englisch übersetzen lassen.
Zum Beispiel nicht ins Deutsche, schade.
Und die Textqualität ist auf jeden Fall schlechter bei meinen Tests als die automatisch übersetzten YouTube-Untertitel.
Und die sind auch schon eher nicht so richtig gut.
Ja.
Aber warum ist da so ein hässliches Ding drüber, Alter, über deinen kompletten Desktop?
Sag mal, wie beschissen kann man sowas machen?
Ist das eine Windows-Forbes-Anwendung oder was?
Dann haben wir noch ganz doll die Windows Studio Effects.
Da soll man so dolle Echtzeit-Video-Effekte mit dem Webcam-Bild machen können.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Augen immer so aussehen, als würden die in die Kamera gucken.
Ja, das ist super creepy. Das gab es ja von Nvidia schon vor einer Weile.
Obwohl man gerade irgendwo anders hinguckt.
Aber, obwohl ich hier mit so einer Dell Ultra Sharp so eine ziemlich Standard-Webcam habe,
funktioniert das mit den studio effekts nicht okay ja und dann gibt es noch die co pilot funktion in
paint ja es ist ja auch unklar was in die cloud geschickt wird und was lokal läuft auf alle fälle
kann ich mit fug und recht behaupten auf meinem system funktionieren viele sachen gar nicht die
frage ist hat überhaupt irgendwas funktioniert beispiel sticker generator das habe ich wirklich
Ich hab wirklich zehnmal neu gestartet, immer wieder neu probiert und da kommt einfach nichts, egal wie lange ich warte.
Und bei Co-Creator, wo man sowas kritzeln kann und dann wird das besser gemacht, funktionierte bei mir in neun von zehn Fällen auch nicht.
Einmal habe ich es geschafft, dass da so ein Schwein generiert wurde.
Das hatte aber rein gar nichts mit dem zu tun, was ich da vorher gekritzelt habe.
Also, was soll ich sagen? Ich habe die KI-Funktion sehr intensiv gesucht in der Akte.
Boah, ist das schlecht. Also ich meine, ich habe die Dinger nie verwendet, weil ich keinen Bock auf KI gedönst.
Aber selbst wenn man es verwendet, ist es richtig schlecht einfach nur.
...aktuellen Windows 11 Version und ja, ich habe sie nicht gefunden.
Also klar, es gibt immer mehr Software, die vorhandene NPUs unterstützt, ganz klar.
Also unter anderem Adobe-Programme und auch sowas wie DaVinci Resolve.
Aber in diesem Video geht es ja um Windows.
Und Microsoft versucht ja auch Windows als KI-Betriebssystem mit diesem Label Copilot Plus zu verkaufen, seit Jahren schon und da kommt bislang irgendwie nicht so viel.
Das kann man glaube ich sagen.
So, hier jetzt noch mal ein versprochener Einschub mit den aller aller neuesten Windows 11 Versionen, auch den Vorab-Versionen.
Ich habe mir extra so lange Zeit gelassen, wie es ging, damit es eben nicht heißt, wenn das Video hier veröffentlicht ist, dass Microsoft das doch alles schon repariert hat.
Also das offizielle, also das normale Windows 11 25H2, das habe ich nochmal mit dem Patchstand vom 19. Mai 2026 ausprobiert.
Und tatsächlich, ich weiß nicht genau woran es lag, ob es tatsächlich ein Patch war oder keine Ahnung, die Mondphase.
Jedenfalls hat die Bildgenerierung in Paint jetzt zuverlässig funktioniert.
Also sowohl dieses Sticker als auch das Co-Creation Tool, wo man was zeichnet und dann wird das generiert.
Was schön ist, das läuft alles lokal.
futuristisches Logo, da kommt sowas bei raus.
Was willst du denn damit anfangen?
Auf der NPU konnte ich auf jeden Fall im Taskmanager nachvollziehen.
Was nicht so schön ist, beides halte ich für nicht wirklich brauchbar.
Hier seht ihr zum Beispiel 3003-Sticker, ja okay.
Und hier Co-Creation, wo ich 3003 dahin gekritzelt habe.
Ja, da hat das generierte Bild jetzt wenig mit zu tun.
Alles andere in diesem Video kritisierte, wurde nicht repariert.
So, und jetzt habe ich noch eine Vorab-Version ausprobiert.
Dafür muss man sich im Update Dialog in Windows Insider anmelden.
Ich habe die Experimental Preview Build 26.
Also neuer geht es nicht mehr.
308493 vom 15. Mai 2026 getestet.
Und da soll jetzt laut der Microsoft Dokumentation endlich die Taskleisten Position geändert werden können.
Aber nein, klappt hier nicht.
Offenbar hat das damit zu tun, dass die Verbesserungen graduell ausgerollt werden.
Ja, schade.
Was allerdings funktioniert und was ich auch ganz gut finde, man kann die Taskleiste insgesamt jetzt kleiner machen.
Aber leider alles andere im Video erwähnt jetzt.
Boah, dafür hast du aber schon einmal ein halbes Jahr gebraucht von 150 Entwicklern oder so.
Das ist schon ein anspruchsvoller Job, ey.
Immer noch genauso kaputt.
Was ich vor allem sehr betr...
Wahrscheinlich haben wir ein halbes Jahr dafür gebraucht, einen Prompt zu erstellen, dass da was Brauchbares rauskam am Ende.
zeichnet fand, nach dem Update auf diese
Vorab-Version hat Windows gemeldet, ich müsste
hier noch was einstellen, bevor ich die neue
Version verwenden kann. Und was war es
wichtiges? Werbung. Unter anderem
für Game Pass Premium.
Okay, dass Microsoft sagt, sie müssen
dringend Windows nachbessern,
das würde ich auch durchaus
für sinnvoll halten. Also,
wenn man bedenkt, dass Windows wirklich mal
das Flaggschiff-Produkt von Microsoft
gewesen ist und eigentlich auch das Produkt,
dem Microsoft vieles, wenn
nicht sogar alles zu verdanken hat,
dann ist das wirklich herzerbrechend.
Wie der Zustand.
Ja, da kann er jetzt zu Recht weinen, der Windows-
Chef.
Dieses Produkt aktuell ist, also
Windows 11, dass sowas Grundlegendes
wie Einloggen in den Account
bei meiner Installation mit unterschiedlichen
Versuchen und mit unterschiedlichen Problemen
einfach nicht funktioniert.
Das ist ja fatal.
Okay, dann dieser ganze Werbekram.
Das ist vielleicht eine Stilfrage.
Ich finde es peinlich, aber gut.
Dass man aber wirklich so rudimentäre Sachen, die auch schon so lange kritisiert werden, wie die sich widersprechenden Einstellmenüs und das komische doppelte Rechtsklickmenü, dass das...
Ja, ich finde, man sieht aber schon, Microsoft hat überhaupt keinen Fokus mehr auf Windows. Das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
alles nicht repariert wird und dass man dann obendrauf noch so ein Brimborium über KI-Funktionen macht,
die dann nicht nur unbrauchbar sind, sondern manchmal auch gar nicht funktionieren.
Also, puh. Und all das sind ja nur die Sachen, die ich selbst hier für dieses Video beobachtet habe.
Also mit eigenen Augen hier dokumentiert. Die ganzen anderen Bugs, von denen etliche Leute immer wieder berichten,
die habe ich hier ja nicht mal erwähnt.
Also Microsoft, ran da, es gibt wirklich viel zu tun. Oder was meint ihr? Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben, gerne Daumen nach oben.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops. Wir sind, ich habe es schon oft gesagt, wir sind quasi so nah dran am Jahr des Linux-Desktops wie noch nie und das liegt nur bedingt am Linux-Desktop, sondern das Microsoft verkackt ohne Ende die letzten paar Jahre, aber es wird natürlich nach wie vor nicht das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben.
Es gibt so eine
schleichende Entwicklung
zu immer mehr Linux auf dem Desktop.
So, das
heute hat es keiner, nächstes Jahr haben es alle,
das wird es logischerweise nicht geben.
...
Was ist das denn?
Sie suchen Ruhe und Entschleunigung? Dann kommen Sie nach Siebelding in der Pfalz, wo die Zeit stehen bleibt und das Internet auch.
Doch die Zukunft ist unterwegs. Das schnelle Internet kommt bald. Allerdings erst in den Wald.
Wir hätten schon gern erst das Internet hier in Siebeldingen gehabt, also im Ort.
Das ist schon wieder...
Das macht schon irgendwie Sinn, ne?
... und auch irgendwie nicht nachvollziehbar, dass man jetzt auf die Siebeldinger Hütte
Glasfaser legt und hier im Ort wird's gebraucht.
Das ist halt wieder... Das hat hundertpro irgendeine bürokratische
Vorschrift in Deutschland, warum das so ist.
Jaha, wer in Siebeldingen schnelles Internet will, braucht ein Auto und Kondition.
Sie müssen 15 km raus in den Pfälzer Wald,
diesen Weg entlangwandern, vorbei am Forellenweiher,
145 Höhenmeter überwinden und zack, Empfang.
An der Siebeldinger Waldhütte, dem neuen Highspeed-Mekka der Pfalz.
Es ist verwunderlich,
dass man über 3 km Glasfaser verlegt, nur für eine Hütte.
Das kostet doch auch.
Die sonntags von 10 bis 18 Uhr geöffnet ist
und ansonsten geschlossen ist.
Eine Hütte, die auf der Menükarte Flash-Knip mit Meerrettich hat.
Und bald eine Upload-Rate wie ein Rechenzentrum in Tokio.
Wir haben alle gelacht. Herzlich gelacht.
Aber was anderes bleibt dir auch nicht übrig.
Ich meine, es gibt ja in Deutschland so komische Regelungen.
Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es das noch gibt oder ob das jetzt damit was zu tun hat.
Aber es gibt ja in Deutschland oder gab zumindest in Deutschland so komische Regelungen,
dass wenn einmal ausgebaut wurde mit irgendwelchen Fördergeldern, dann darf dort quasi die nächsten, keine Ahnung, 10 Jahre oder so nicht mehr ausgebaut werden.
Vielleicht ist das sowas. Vielleicht wurde ja da irgendwann einmal 2016 noch VDSL ausgebaut und jetzt dürfen sie erstmal nicht mehr.
Wir haben in Deutschland super krass viel Bürokratie und Vorschriften. Teilweise so, dass man komplett gelähmt ist und nichts mehr machen kann.
Irgendwas in der Richtung wird das schon sein.
Die falsche Richtung, weil auf der Waldhütte lebt niemand, aber hier im Ort leben 4000 Menschen, die auch noch keine Glasfaser haben.
Bei uns klappt gar nichts und in der Hütte, da wird das Geld rausgeballert. Aber wir haben es ja gern.
Dank des Förderprogramms Glasfaserausbau in weißen Flecken werden abgelegene Bereiche, die für private Anbieter unrentabel sind, beim Glasfaserausbau staatlich unterstützt.
Und der Landkreis Südliche Weinstraße hat für die Pfälzer Waldhütten eine Förderung bekommen.
Geld, das man nicht ablehnen kann.
Klar freuen wir uns über das Geld und es ist die einmalige Chance, jetzt Breitband auch an diese Grundstücke zu verlegen.
Ich hätte auch natürlich lieber, dass die Ortschaften bei uns versorgt werden mit Breitband, alle.
Das haben wir aber nicht in der Hand und das ist nicht Bestandteil der Förderprojekte.
Nein, Sie bedingen es nicht.
Da lag ich doch gar nicht so verkehrt, oder?
mit meiner Vermutung, dass es irgendwas in der Richtung damit zu tun hat.
... abgelegen genug, aber die Siebeldinger Waldhütte. Und die kriegt nun exklusiv eine 3,5 Kilometer lange Glasfaserleitung für circa 400.000 Euro.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich viel dringender Strom. Und aktuell läuft das über einen Generator hier.
Und das wäre doch schön, wenn...
Moment, Glasfaser, aber kein Strom. Ja, warum nicht?
Man in dem Zug nehmen das Glasfaserkabel.
Das geht nicht, das machen ja unterschiedliche Leute wahrscheinlich, die dafür zuständig sind.
Noch ein Stromkabel legen kann.
Könnte man, aber das kostet extra. Sorry.
Dafür bekommt die Waldhütte Hochgeschwindigkeits-Internet und bietet ganz neue Möglichkeiten.
Solange wir hier kein Glasfaser haben, nehmen wir unseren Laptop und wandern zur Sieblinger Hütte und machen dort unser Homeoffice.
So geht Digitalisierung auf Pfälzisch
Mit dem Laptop zum Silicon Forest
Naja
Da gibt es tausendfache Sachen
In Deutschland wurde der echt dein Kopfkreis
Das kriege ich ja eigentlich wieder für komisches Zeug empfohlen
Nicht dass ich das sonst gucken würde
ETF
npal die haben ja auch letztens werbung geschickt dass sie furchtbar gerne bei
mir glasfaser nicht glasfaser wtf photovoltaik bauen wollen sich gleich in
müll geschmissen ok genau wir kommen wasser
wasser vor ist hat auf youtube
ist das der richtige channel
warum plötzlich alle chinesische kais nutzen ob jetzt minuten ist so lang
zahlt geistig geister aus mit so anspruchsvoll
German Brain Rot. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es mittlerweile
sogar auch German Brain Rot gibt.
Italienischer Brain Rot.
Kenn ich.
Und wär froh, wenn ich's nicht kennen würde.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Mit 25 schon Chef von 25 Leuten.
So viel verdienen. Ein Biergartenbesitzer.
Ja, das ist doch mal was.
Wahrscheinlich was anderes.
Ich muss gerade noch mal kurz gucken, ob da irgendwas
ist, wo ich auch inhaltlich was zu
sagen kann. In letzter Zeit.
Musiker, Kaminkehrer,
Schwimmlehrer.
Chat.
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch.
Weil ich gerade Schwimmlehrer
gelesen habe.
Ich
will öfters mal wieder schwimmen gehen.
Und
also ich kann schwimmen.
Ich habe mir aber überlegt,
ich würde gerne
kraulen lernen.
Und gibt es
irgendwie eine Möglichkeit? Also kennt
ihr sowas? Gibt es irgendwelche
Schwimmkurse für Erwachsene, wo es nicht
darum geht, schwimmen zu lernen,
sondern bestimmte
bestimmte
Schwimmstile zu lernen.
Katzenkraulen.
Kraulen.
Ja, das...
Sowas würde ich nämlich gerne machen.
Dass dann auch mal einer guckt und es einem erklärt.
Also ein bisschen kann ich das von früher noch.
Aber ich konnte das nie wirklich gut.
Und...
Ich habe mir nämlich überlegt, jetzt gerade wo schönes Wetter ist und ich mache ja oftmals nach dem Homeoffice meine Sporteinheit, da könnte man richtig schwimmen.
Technik-Kurs. Okay, so war es in der Richtung.
Genau. Weil ich könnte
beispielsweise
vier Kilometer
zum Schwimmbad hin joggen,
dann eine Weile meine Runden
schwimmen und dann vier Kilometer
wieder zurück joggen. Das wäre eine richtig
gute, nice
Trainingsrunde.
Also
früher konnte ich richtig gut schwimmen.
Ich konnte fünf Kilometer schwimmen.
Also das sind das 100 100 bahnen oder so
War richtig gut ich hatte ich hatte sogar dieses silberne silberne schwimm abzeichen deutsche schwimm abzeichen
Ohne strecke mit dem fahrrad ja könnte ich theoretisch auch machen aber ich glaube vier kilometer rennen schwimmen vier kilometer zurück reicht mal
Mit dem Rad zum Schwimmbad und zu Fuß zurück.
Und was passiert dann mit dem Fahrrad, was da ist?
Das klaut.
Achso, ah, verstehe, verstehe.
ok zeit mal kurz hier muss man kurz gucken frankfurt stadt events richtig
schwimmen technikkurse für erwachsene
ausrüstung badebekleidung war der hose handtuch schon brille
Äh, und an welchem, in welchem Schwimmbad ist das jetzt?
Hanauer Landstraße?
Fitness First.
Wo ist das?
Wo, wo ist das?
Das ist richtig unangenehm.
Tja.
Also Brustschwimmen kann ich ganz gut.
Auf der Hanauer Landstraße war das doch, oder?
Egal.
Ich guck mir das...
Muss ich mir jetzt nicht im Stream angucken.
Aber...
Wie schwimmst du Brust?
Äh.
Wie man halt Brust schwimmt.
Mit Kopf unter Wasser?
Ne.
Also kann ich auch, konnte ich zumindest früher.
Jetzt würde ich das ohne Kopf unter Wasser machen.
Wie gesagt, ich war richtig lange nicht mehr schwimmen, aber ich habe gerade diesen Sommer jetzt voll Bock drauf.
Schwimmen ist mega Workout.
Ja, ich stelle mir die Kombination echt ganz nice vor.
Also wie gesagt, früher konnte ich kilometerweit schwimmen.
Aber da war ich noch jung und fit.
Jetzt bin ich mittlerweile auch halbwegs fit, aber nicht mehr jung.
Ähm.
Chatkill.
Aber irgendwie habe ich da Bock drauf.
Und gerade so die Kombination 4 Kilometer zum Schwimmbad hinrennen,
Runde schwimmen gehen, 4 Kilometer zurück,
stelle ich mir richtig gute Trainingseinheit vor.
Ich glaube, das Salami-Emote wurde gelöscht.
Der Chainlore hatte mal eins gebaut,
aber die haben ja den Account vom Chainlore gelöscht.
Ach nee, hier Wuppwurst gibt es noch.
Guck mal.
Wupp Wupp Wurst.
Gibt es heute endlich wieder Lachsnudeln?
Ja, heute gibt es Nudeln mit Lachs.
Du hast es erkannt.
Nudeln mit Lachs gibt es heute.
Es wurde echt mal wieder Zeit, ne?
Aber heute gibt's traditionell
Die Mikro war leer
Um die Uhrzeit macht die noch nix
Muss ich gar nicht gucken
So, aber gucken wir uns noch mal an
Was der Biergartenbesitzer macht
Ich predikte jetzt schon mal ne Sache
Das ist echt anstrengende Arbeit
Biergarten
So, bitteschön
Ab Mitte Oktober hab ich keine Einnahmen
Bis ungefähr
Ab Mitte Oktober habe ich keine Einnahmen bis ungefähr Anfang April.
So, ey das gibt's nicht.
Unser Bon-Drucker will irgendwie nicht.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Meint ihr das sind 1080p at 50, weil es vom Bayerischen Rundfunk ist und die noch irgendwie
auf der Wiederholfrequenz von PAL stehen geblieben sind?
Sonst macht die ganze Welt 60.
macht halt keinen Sinn mehr bei 1080p 50.
Okay, ich darf nichts sagen.
Ich habe auch 1080p 48 FPS.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber bei mir beim Streamen liegt es halt auch daran,
weil es die Bildqualität noch ein bisschen besser macht.
Und nahezu genauso flüssig erscheint wie 60.
Es kann natürlich keine Ware rausgeben.
Nee.
Hallo, ich bin Luca, ich bin 25 Jahre alt und habe einen Biergarten.
Das Wetter soll morgen, ja so 19 Grad Regen.
Oh, Vatertag, da wird's voll.
Vielleicht auch Gewitter werden, mal gucken.
Der Vatertag ist natürlich ein wichtiger Tag.
Ist so einer der umsatzstärksten Tage in der Regel, in der Range so von den 10.
Mich würde interessieren, was bei ihm ein Bier kostet.
Das ist doch bestimmt mittlerweile brutalst teuer.
Den wichtigsten Tagen im Jahr.
Hier haben wir morgen unsere Band, das ist schon vorbereitet als Bühne.
Ich bete, dass sie nicht von sich aus absagen,
weil sie sagen, es ist zu kalt, zu wetterunsicher.
Wir haben immer viel Bier da, dass das nie leer geht.
Das sind jetzt rund 30 Fässer, 900 Liter.
An so einem regulären Vatertag sind wir so bei 300 Liter.
Wenn wir morgen 150 haben, wär das schon top.
Am Bier haben wir ungefähr Kosten von so 1,20 Euro.
Und verkaufen uns dann für fünf Euro den halben Liter.
Fünf Euro für ein Glas Bier, krass.
Ich mein, klar, Oktoberfest ist noch teurer, der Liter, aber ist schon teuer.
Boah, ist echt kalt, ne?
Heute unter den Umständen wäre ein guter Umsatz, ich denke, 4.000 Euro.
Ich hab am Vatertag letztes Jahr circa 8.000 Euro verdient.
Max, trinkst du Alkohol?
Ne, so gut wie nicht.
Und ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe in letzter Zeit auch enorm wenig Fleisch gegessen.
Ich futter zunehmend nur Salat mit einem Brötchen dabei auf der Arbeit
oder die Vegetarier- und Veganermahlzeit.
Aber keine Sorge, ich werde euch nicht versuchen zu bekehren.
Ich bin ja selbst noch nicht mal bekehrt.
Aber ich versuche ein bisschen weniger Fleisch zu essen,
weil das ja auch auf Dauer jetzt nicht das Allergesündeste ist,
sich da voll zu stopfen, immer mit Fleisch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich wirklich Veganer,
so Hardcore-Veganer werde,
das glaube ich nicht.
Aber ich habe die letzte Woche
so gut wie kein Fleisch gefuttert.
Also wirklich, mir fällt jetzt
kein Tag ein, wo da irgendwie viel Fleisch war.
Hast du auch schon mal über Sport gesagt.
Ja.
Gestern habe ich
die Garmin-Uhr
die falsche Garmin-Uhr angehabt.
Ich habe aus Versehen die Garmin-Uhr
von meiner Mutter angezogen.
Das ist die gleiche Uhr.
Exakt die gleiche Uhr.
Und das habe ich erst gemerkt,
wie ich rausgegangen bin.
Also beziehungsweise, wie ich rausgegangen bin,
losgerannt bin und es eingeschaltet habe.
Ich habe gedacht, Moment, irgendwie sieht die Anzeige
so merkwürdig aus.
Und da bin ich mit der Uhr gerannt.
Die hat den größten Bullshit aller Zeiten angezeigt,
die Garmin-Uhr.
Die hat bis 150er Puls, war die der Meinung, ich bin in Ruhe und ab 155 oder so hat die angezeigt Aufwärmphase. Also die war komplett neben der Spur die Uhr.
Und am Ende hat die dann angezeigt, Maximalpuls 166 oder sowas, komplett verkehrt.
Und beste Geschwindigkeit, die ich rennen sollte, wären 7 Minuten 15 pro Kilometer.
Tag davor bin ich 7 Kilometer gerannt mit 6 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Keine Ahnung, also die Uhr hat
Aber das ist klar, ich meine die Uhr hat sich jetzt ja quasi
An meine Mutter gewöhnt, ja
Und die war
Hat die komplett verwirrt
Dass ich damit gerannt bin
Dementsprechend hat die auch komplett Bullshit angezeigt
Ich meine allein schon
Ich meine allein schon, guck mal
Die hat mir angezeigt, so meine
Laktatgrenze oder wie das heißt
Also da, wo du quasi ohne Probleme längere Zeit mit rennen kannst, weil du so viel Laktat produzierst, wie du auch wieder abbauen kannst, liegt bei einem 153er Puls.
Aber angeblich ist mein Maximalpuls nur 166.
Allein schon das ergibt ja keinen Sinn. Also die Uhr hat kompletten Bullshit angezeigt.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns aber das Video mal an.
Ich habe mir ein Eisfahrrad selbst gebaut, das war so mit 16 und der Vorbesitzer kannte mich vom Biergarten und hat mich dann irgendwann gefragt,
hey, hast du nicht Lust, hier auch den Biergarten zu übernehmen? Und das laufende Geschäft vom Biergarten habe ich...
Richtiger Macher, hä?
Im Prinzip aus den ganzen Einnahmen finanziert, die ich schon vorher hatte aus meiner selbstständigen Tätigkeit.
Und der Vorbesitzer ist mir entgegengekommen und ich hatte ein bisschen Luft nach hinten raus und musste ihm sozusagen den Abstand vom Biergarten erst später zeigen.
Gute Frage mit Kartenzahlung, ja.
Die Ersten!
Ja.
Ihr seid die Ersten.
Wir haben gerade Jägermeister für einen Euro.
ist es auf jeden Fall häufig so,
dass irgendwie ein Problem auftritt
und man das kurzfristig lösen
muss. Typische Probleme sind
eigentlich genau alles, was irgendwie mit Strom,
mit Internet, Netzwerktechnik zu tun hat
und Kasse natürlich.
Ah, guck mal, die haben
ein Kartenlesegerät, ha?
Das finde ich schon mal gut, weil mich fuckt das
immer ab, wenn du, ähm,
also
ich habe ja so gut wie nie Bargeld dabei.
Ich habe ein paar Euro im Rucksack.
Wenn du dann in irgendeinen Laden reinkommst, denkst du, ich würde mir jetzt gerne noch ein Eis holen oder so, dann steht da, keine Kartenzahlung.
Na gut, dann gehe ich halt wieder raus.
Los.
So, ich weiß nicht.
Unser Bon-Drucker will irgendwie nicht.
Ohne Bon-Drucker keine Kasse.
Weil die Kasse springt dann auch nicht auf.
Ja, können wir im schlimmsten Fall natürlich keine Ware rausgeben, weil es muss ja immer für den Kunden Bon gedruckt werden.
Und wenn wir keinen Bon drucken können, dürfen wir nicht kassieren.
Ich suche mal ein neues Kabel und dann wechsle ich das aus.
Ich habe hier tatsächlich vor ein paar Tagen umgebaut.
Läuft das auch mit Windows?
Weil es mal an einem Tag geht und am anderen nicht?
Wo wir nicht aufgemacht haben, habe ich ein bisschen was an der Netzwerktechnik gefummelt
und seitdem habe ich es doberweise auch nicht ausprobiert, ob es denn auch geht.
Ich ärgere mich auf jeden Fall, dass ich es nicht getestet habe.
man testen müssen, gerade bei einer Kasse, was ja auch wirklich total entscheidend ist.
Für hier gar kein Drucker geht. So, oh, was ist passiert?
Das ist schon mal gut. Das ist jetzt nur der hier, der nicht will. Also wir haben hier zwei
Bon-Drucker. Mit NixOS wäre das nicht passiert. Da wäre es reproduzierbar.
Sie sagen eigentlich nur die Bestellbons an, dass wenn viel los ist, einer kassiert und einer
arbeitet hier sozusagen die Bonds alle ab.
Ich würde das jetzt einfach auf
den anderen Bong-Drucker umpolen
und dann ist das jetzt erstmal so die Lösung
für heute. Was hat der für ein OS?
Lass mal kurz gucken, ich hab nicht geguckt.
Mac OS, oder?
Ist das ein Mac?
Ja, das ist ein Mac. Und dann
ist das jetzt erstmal so die Lösung für heute.
Ja, das hat geklappt.
Jetzt läuft er auf jeden Fall wieder.
Das ist beruhigend. Es läuft.
Ich würde jetzt nach Hannover fahren, zu den Rittlinger Kies-Teilchen.
Da haben wir noch einen zweiten Standort, der ist zwar heute zu wetterbedingt, aber
morgen geht es da weiter und ich würde da jetzt einfach schnell noch mal ein bisschen
Ware hinbringen.
Ja, der ist von morgens bis abends halt beschäftigt.
Geht nicht.
Okay, 60 Prozent machen Kartenzahlung.
Okay, ich guck gleich nochmal am Auto kurz.
Einmal kurz gucken, was hier mit der Kasse ist.
Unter den Einstell- Ja, irgendwie so.
Das sagt er dir dann.
Okay, ciao.
Da ist immer so ein bisschen das Risiko, dass man hier voll auffährt, vom Besten aus.
Das ist aber auch Kacke, wenn die Kasse nicht geht.
Das ist eines der wichtigsten Sachen.
Du musst ja Geld bekommen.
Es ist sicher, dass auch viele Gäste kommen und die Kosten sind da.
Aber wenn keine Kunden kommen, dann geht so ein Tag auch mal ganz übel aus.
Wir sind jetzt an den Ricklinger Kies-Teichen.
Ich habe hier noch den Kies-Kauer.
Hier haben wir noch so einen kleinen Imbiss mit Eis und Bier.
So, dann würde ich jetzt hier einmal die Ware schnell mal aufpacken.
Da haben wir nur einen Top-Tagen auf, wo wir dann auf jeden Fall mit viel Publikumsverkehr rechnen.
Ja, ist ein Nebengeschäft, davon kann keiner leben, aber ist eine nette Zusatzeinnahme.
Wir fahren jetzt wieder zurück nach Seels im Biergarten und gucken mal, ob da jetzt schon ein paar Leute eingetrudelt sind.
Dann ruft der Biergarten schon an. Ja.
Hallo Luca, die Band ist jetzt da.
Ach, hi.
Hi.
Irgendwie wird das natürlich heute.
Nein, das ist gut.
Aber wir gucken mal.
Die Band ist da.
Wir gucken mal. Ich hoffe, es kommen jetzt alle wegen euch.
Na ihr?
Na.
Ich hänge noch in der.
mich nervt live musik immer weil oder generell also festtagen weil wir haben
ein paar restaurants hier die machen dann immer riesen ding draußen mit bands
mit lautsprechern die übelste das geht ihr so sehr auf den sack selbst wenn ich
abends im bett liegt teilweise wenn ich 22 ins bett gehe ist da immer noch
gedudelt gedudelt gedödel am start aber ich beschwere mich nicht ich denke mir die leute
wollen auch ihren spaß haben das kann ja nicht alle immer so keller kindmäßig wie ich unterwegs
sein ist ja okay ja die dürfen auch ihren spaß haben aber es nervt mich trotzdem das gibt es
nicht ja also drucker ausgang hat jetzt gedruckt moment der wahrheit ja wohl funktioniert läuft
wieder alles. Eine Stunde haben wir jetzt insgesamt mit dem telefoniert.
Kann sich der Support remote einwählen auf die Kasse oder so?
12 Bier.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Okay.
Ja gut. Dann wird halt getosst.
Wenn ein Gast zu betrunken ist, sich gar nicht mehr auf den Beinen halten kann, dann schenkt
mir natürlich nichts aufs und helfen, unterstützen ihn oder rufen auch ein Taxi für ihn.
Einmal Weizen, Alkoholwohle.
Das sind dann die Leute, die da erzählen, ich kann easy noch heimfahren, kein Problem.
Haben wir noch Rippchen da?
Nein.
Raus.
Was, Schlitze haben wir da?
Jetzt, wenn die Sonne mal rauskommt, ist doch toll, ne?
Das sind bestimmt irgendwelche Tiefkühlschlitzel, die in die Fritteuse gehauen werden.
Und jetzt ist auch ein bisschen was los endlich. Wir sind auf jeden Fall heute im positiven Bereich und müssen nicht draufzahlen. Das ist schon mal gut. Wir schlagen uns so durch.
Na ist doch trotzdem ganz gut was los. Obwohl Vatertag schlechtes Wetter ist.
Grundlegend ist es so, dass ich natürlich im Sommer das Geld verdiene.
Gerade so in den drei, vier Monaten Juni, Juli, August und September. Das sind so die Hauptmonate.
Bist du am Vatertag auch mit dem Bollerwagen unterwegs?
Nee.
Wo wir das Geld verdienen. Und im Winter sind natürlich keine Einnahmen da.
Und im Winter bauen wir dann gerne um. Und ich weiß genau, okay, was habe ich das Jahr verdient und was kann ich dann noch in Umbauten stecken und Investitionen.
Nicht schlecht, die Band hat vier Stunden da jetzt Dauer gespielt, das ist auch anstrengend.
Ich würde jetzt einmal die Ware kontrollieren, ich würde jetzt gleich einmal im Ausschank nochmal fragen, ob da irgendwie was fehlt, dann selber auch nochmal durchgucken, in der Küche fragen und dann mir mal...
Bei uns war letztens hier, weil du schreibst Traktor,
Tschätke, weil ihr gerade schreibt Traktor.
Bei uns war hier letztens irgendwie um die Ecke
so ein Traktortreffen oder sowas.
Da standen auf der Brücke,
also neben der Brücke,
standen dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 50 Traktor-Dinger
so in der Reihe. Und du konntest dich
dann da auch einmal im Kreis fahren lassen
mit dem Traktor und sowas. Ganz komisches Zeug.
Habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich bin nicht mit dem Traktor gefahren.
Ich bin nur ein paar Mal dran vorbeigerannt
und habe es gesehen.
irgendwie, was weiß ich,
hessisches Traktor,
Oldtimer-Traktor-Treffen oder sowas.
Ein Handy schnappen und
die Bestellung vervollständigen.
Fehlt denn irgendwas an Ware?
Kian, ist dir was aufgefallen?
Energy ist noch.
Baileys gibt's nicht.
Ja, ist schon bestellt.
Alles klar. Ich guck auch noch mal durch.
Der hat halt echt was zu tun.
Der steht da morgens um sieben
Auf dem Ding und jetzt ist es 20 Uhr, da sind wir noch am Start.
Und das geht noch ein paar Stunden.
So, jetzt wird es kalt.
Bier haben wir noch.
Also Zwischenstand würde ich sagen, es sind ungefähr heute so 120 Liter aus dem Bauch heraus verkauft worden.
Also an dem, was wir jetzt prognostiziert hatten mit 150 Litern, sind wir gar nicht so weit entfernt.
Maracuja-Saft fehlt, wenn ich das richtig überblicke.
Hafermilch fehlt.
Vollmilch fehlt.
Aporosa-Tee, das sieht alles top aus.
Ich will jetzt einmal den Umsatz checken,
wo wir heute gestanden haben.
3.561,30 Cent war jetzt der Umsatz.
Für das Wetter genau das, was es sein sollte.
Da bin ich voll zufrieden.
Dann mach ich jetzt Feierabend.
Ciao, schönen Feierabend.
Ciao, war schön, ne?
Ja, ich bin zufrieden, wie der Tag lief.
Ich glaube,
er hätte deutlich besser laufen können.
Da bist du aber auch ganz schön am Arsch, oder?
7 Uhr aufstehen,
jetzt 21 Uhr ist er noch da,
vor 23 Uhr ist er nicht im Bett.
Da war er 16 Stunden unterwegs.
Oder länger, der war um 7 Uhr da,
da ist er wahrscheinlich um 6 Uhr
irgendwie schon aufgestanden.
17 Stunden im Einsatz.
Aber auch deutlich schlechter.
Heute Morgen habe ich noch gedacht,
Wir brechen hier irgendwann um 18, 19 Uhr ab, weil keiner da ist ungefähr.
Mein Jahresumsatz 2025 lag bei 257.500 Euro.
Davon gehen natürlich die ganzen Kosten runter, wie Pacht, Strom, Personal, Wareneinkauf und Investitionen vor allem.
Und vor Steuern hatte ich dann einen Jahresgewinn von 48.000 Euro.
Wenn die Saison vorbei ist, zahle ich mir einen größeren Betrag aus und lebe dann davon.
Letztes Jahr war ich mit meinem Gewinn zufrieden.
Und?
zahle ich mir einen größeren Betrag aus.
Warum musst du denn nur 450 Euro für die private Krankenversicherung bezahlen?
Was ist da los? Warum bezahle ich 850 Euro?
Was ist da? Was ist hier? Was ist das? Was ist sein Geheimnis?
Okay, der ist eine ganze Ecke jünger als ich, das stimmt.
Und lebe dann davon.
Letztes Jahr war ich mit meinem Gewinn zufrieden.
Ich habe natürlich auch viel investiert, also hätte ich weniger investiert, hätte ich auch natürlich einen höheren Gewinn.
Ich denke, dieses Jahr werden wir nochmal unseren Umsatz um 20 Prozent steigern können,
gerade weil wir dieses Jahr viel mehr Events haben und auch noch die Fußball-WM anspielt.
Ja, das ist das Wohnzimmer. Lina hat jetzt auch schon angefangen, Essen vorzubereiten.
Ich wohne zusammen mit meiner Freundin.
Ich hätte gedacht, sie hauen sich jetzt auch so einen Metro-Schnitzel noch in die Pfanne.
Meine Freundin ist ja Studentin, sie zahlt keine Mieter.
Die Wohnung soll schon irgendwie die Basis sein und man soll sich wohlfühlen.
Und dann darf sie auch einen großen Teil vom Gehalt ausmachen.
Mein nächster finanzieller Traum ist auf jeden Fall, über 100.000 Euro im Jahr Gewinn zu machen.
Und materiell wäre mein nächster Traum, ich würde gerne einen Porsche Oldtimer fahren.
Toss, toss, toss, toss.
Ich mach mal leiser.
Ah ja, der schafft auch von neun bis abends.
Nicht wie diese eine Marketingfrau, die sie da mal hatten.
Das war das Schlimmste hier.
Egal, das war nix.
Die hatten wir schon geguckt, ne?
Umweltstartup.
Oder?
Schwimmlehrer?
Ich mache
einen Kurs demnächst, ja, aber
was der verdient, muss ich mir nicht angucken.
Das Verdi-Video
wurde gelöscht. Was gab es da?
Ne, das haben wir geguckt, Marketing-Startup.
Das hier haben wir uns
gar nicht angeguckt.
Ein KI-Startup.
Oh, das wird cringe, Leute.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Das wird grausam.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Das wird schlimm.
Das kommen wir jetzt gleich noch hinterher.
Finanziell hat es sich nicht gelohnt.
Moment, das haben wir doch schon geguckt, oder?
Haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Hallo, ich bin die Stimme ihres Telefonassistenten.
Die schlaflosen Nächte gibt's.
Die grauen Haare sind wahrscheinlich auch daher.
In den letzten Monaten hatten wir jedes Mal von Monat zu Monat so einen Umsatzsprung,
wie quasi in den ersten vier Jahren in Summe.
Ohoho.
Hi, ich bin Tobias, 35 Jahre alt.
Und mein Name ist Thomas, 37 Jahre alt.
Und wir haben hier in Nürnberg ein Startup gegründet, das KI-basierte Telefon.
Wisst ihr, woran man merkt, dass man alt ist?
wenn irgendwie gefühlt in jedem Beitrag
die Leute jünger sind als man selbst
ich werde dieses Jahr 42
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen
WTF
ich seh bestimmt besser aus
mag sein
ich bin aber trotzdem so alt
zum glück werde ich nicht 67
homelab mistakes okay das kann man sagen
von assistenten anbietet die wollen jetzt mal eine testphase machen mit unserer mit unserer
Software mit unserem Telefonassistenten. Wir sind heute hier, um dir den mal vorzustellen.
Hallo! Thomas Abend, hallo! Hallo, Herr Bäumler!
Julius Bäumler, hallo!
Können Sie abschätzen, wie viele Anrufe so ungefähr täglich reinkommen?
Also ich würde mal sagen, das sind mindestens 300 Anrufe am Tag.
Ja, wow! Minimum. Ja, wow. Wenn nicht noch mehr.
Und die Anrufe wollen Sie jetzt abf... die Anrufer wollen Sie jetzt abfacken mit
irgendeiner KI. Ja, das ist schon eine Hausnummer. Was sind denn so die typischen Anrufgründe? Sind
die Einlagen fertig oder ist die Prothese fertig? Kann ich meine Pflegeprodukte abholen? Das sind
so die Hauptanrufe. Wir automatisieren für uns. Okay, dafür kann ich mir das richtig gut vorstellen
mit einer KI. Das geht bestimmt. Also du könntest natürlich auch einfach das ordentlich auf der
Homepage abfragbar machen, aber es gibt halt immer noch Leute, die sind nicht in der Lage
und wenn das was ist, die Einlagen, Prothesen herstellen, gehen da bestimmt auch viele Omas und Opas
hin, die rufen dann da lieber an.
Das ist tatsächlich mal ein Anwendungsgebiet, wo ich sage,
ja, das kann ich mir durchaus
für KI ganz gut vorstellen.
...nehmen, zum Beispiel für Arztpraxen,
wiederkehrende Anrufe, zum Beispiel Fragen nach dem Termin, nach Rezepten.
Was man am Anfang festlegen muss, ist die Begrüßung. Wie soll der Bot ans Telefon gehen?
Das Schöne ist, es gibt kein Telefonklingeln, keine Warteschleife.
Egal wie viele Anrufe gleichzeitig kommen, der Bot geht immer sofort ans Telefon und nimmt den Anruf an.
Vielleicht hören wir uns ein paar Stimmen an.
Hallo, ich bin die Stimme Ihres Telefonassistenten.
Haben die keine besseren Stimmen?
Das klingt ja schon so krass nach Bot.
Hallo, ich bin die Stimme Ihres Telefonassistenten.
Ohne Coding-Kenntnisse, ohne technische Kenntnisse kann man den Assistenten über unsere Cloud-Oberfläche konfigurieren.
Und der Anspruch an uns selber ist, dass jeder, der ein iPhone bedienen kann,
soll auch in der Lage sein, seinen eigenen Assistenten zu programmieren.
Wir sind der Werkzeugkasten. Wie man das Werkzeug dann einsetzen möchte, das liegt dann ganz bei Ihnen.
Kann sein, dass man sagt, eine Bestellung, nimmt man direkt die Informationen auf oder dass dann auch Terminvereinbarungen direkt über den Assistenten im Kalender landen.
Dann probieren wir es nochmal aus. Mich würden eure Öffnungszeiten mal interessieren.
Die Öffnungszeiten unserer Filialen sind grundsätzlich wie folgt. Die meisten Filialen sind Montag bis Freitag von circa 9 Uhr bis 18 Uhr geöffnet.
Also KI, deswegen ist auch die Jugend dabei. Ich tue mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen schwer mit KI, weil ich mir da nur auch schwer was darunter vorstellen kann. Wir probieren es mal aus.
Dann?
Ich hoffe, wir konnten alle Fragen beantworten.
Dafür hast du jetzt auch drei Rechenzentren und viel RAM gebraucht.
Kann ich dann beantworten?
Für die Öffnungszeit.
Und wenn nicht, dann werden wir uns mitziehen.
Das wäre doch gut.
Da bin ich jetzt zuversichtlich für die Testphase.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Anwendungsfall, wo ich sage, ey, da macht es, klingt für mich voll plausibel.
Und es gibt mittlerweile wirklich gutes Text-to-Speech.
Da erkennst du nicht, dass das ein Bot ist.
Oder da erkennst du nicht, dass es Text-to-Speech ist.
Wenn du jetzt eine Weile an hast, du kommst schon drauf, dass es Text-to-Speech ist.
Also mit Emotionen und so und gerade schnell wechselnd Emotionen und so.
Betonung, da haben die es noch nicht so damit.
Aber die hören sich wirklich gut an mittlerweile.
Wir sind wahnsinnig interessiert gewesen an dem ganzen Thema künstliche Intelligenz, Deep Learning vor allem auch noch in den Anfangsjahren, lange, lange, lange vor dem KI-Hype.
Und wir haben uns umgeschaut und haben festgestellt, dass diese uralt backenden, bitte drücken Sie die 1, bitte drücken Sie die 2, die keiner so richtig leiden kann.
Und wir haben gesagt, mit KI lässt sich da was deutlich Besseres entwickeln.
Das waren die Zeiten, wo die Leute noch mit TensorFlow, hieß das, gell?
Mit TensorFlow Sachen gebastelt haben.
Ach ja, der gute alte Zollhof.
Ich grüße dich.
Hi, schön, dass du da bist.
Servus, hi.
Tobi, alles gut?
Ja, wie geht's euch?
Die sind mir viel zu freundlich und extrovertiert alle.
Aber deswegen bin ich halt auch IT-Kellerkind und die verkaufen ihren Kram.
Und den Kaffee.
Kann ich was anbieten?
Sehr gerne.
Na komm, super.
Auf geht's.
Ausgezeichneten Job gehabt, auch ein sehr guter Arbeitgeber, hat mir auch viel Spaß gemacht.
Auch die gute Karriereaussicht, die ich damals einfach auch hatte, oder mal was eigenes wagen.
Ich habe dann so gedanklich so 30 Jahre in die Zukunft gesehen und habe mir gedacht,
wenn ich dann irgendwie so zurückblicke und dann irgendwie es bereue, es nicht probiert zu haben,
ich glaube, ich hätte mich tierisch geärgert.
Vitas war eigentlich eines unserer ersten KIs, glaube ich.
Ihr wart ja schon wirklich sehr früh dran mit diesem Spracherkennungsthema.
Wir haben tatsächlich angefangen ursprünglich mit der Gastronomie.
Sind teilweise auch von Haustür zu Haustür gelaufen.
Wir haben den Markeneintritt dann im Februar 2020 gemacht.
War natürlich das allerbeste Timing, weil dann quasi durch die Corona-Pandemie
innerhalb von vier Wochen unser kompletter Markt einmal zusammengebrochen ist.
Das war natürlich zwei Jahre Forschung und Entwicklung.
Wahnsinniger Schlag ins Gesicht.
Zuerst ist dann das Geschäftskonto leer, dann sind die Privatenkonten leer.
Da guckt man halt.
Ja, und das ist dann so.
Ist der Kühlschrank leer.
Das sind natürlich dann schon so Phasen, wo man sich denkt, vielleicht hatten doch die Eltern recht gehabt.
Ja, und was machen die jetzt so den ganzen Tag?
So ein sicherer Arbeitgeber wäre doch der...
Außer über ihr Start-up zu erzählen.
Der bessere Weg gewesen.
Aber bevor man das zugibt, macht man weiter.
Augen zu und durch.
Viele Start-ups sagen dann, das war's und wir hatten einfach Glück gehabt.
Wir hatten mit der Kassenärztlichen Bundesvereinigung ein sehr großes Projekt dann eben auch nochmal hinbekommen, wegen Corona.
Und das hat uns dann tatsächlich auch so wirklich auch zur ersten Finanzierungsrunde gebracht.
Und ab dann ging es dann weiter.
Ja genau, die brauchen ja auch ein paar Entwickler und sowas. Oder Vibe-Coden, die das.
Aber einfach war es nie.
Luft ist noch wie damals.
Ja, stimmt.
Servus, hi.
Wir hatten hier diese zwölf Plätze und damals war es auch eine Zeit, wo viele Startups gekommen sind.
und dadurch gab es nicht mehr die Möglichkeit, hier weitere Tische dazu zu buchen.
Und das hat ganz gut funktioniert, bis wir so bei...
Ach, ist das irgendein Startup-Office-Space oder so?
20, 22 Leuten waren...
Ja, stimmt. Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern.
Wir saßen teilweise zu zweit, dann auch pro Schreibtisch. Ja, richtig.
Oh je.
Ich glaube, so ein bisschen größenwahnsinnig muss man als Gründer auch schon sein.
Plötzlich zu sehen, wenn dann mal 20, 30 jetzt beim der letzten Vacation Offsite, wo wir waren, 40 Leute im Vitas Hoodie rumlaufen und man sich so denkt, was ist hier passiert, bringt dann aber auch einfach diese Verantwortung mit sich.
Offside-Event, wo wahrscheinlich keiner Bock drauf hatte,
außer die zwei.
Wobei, es gibt genug Leute, die da drauf Bock haben.
Es sind nicht alle so wie ich.
Ich hab ja immer keinen Bock auf
irgendwelche großartigen Events
und sonst was. Wobei, die letzten waren
gar nicht so schlecht, muss man auch mal Fairness halber sagen.
Ich hab dazu immer keinen Bock drauf, aber die waren
gar nicht schlecht.
Dass man sagt, es darf jetzt auch
irgendwie nicht schief gehen.
Na gut, die machen halt das.
Was notwendig ist, die müssen den Kram verkaufen.
Macht ja irgendwie auch Sinn.
Es bringt ja nichts, wenn du ein gutes System hast und keiner weiß davon.
Seit den letzten Jahren wieder bei uns angekommen als Kunden, weil sie nicht zufrieden waren woanders.
Und jetzt wollen wir mal fragen, wie es da so läuft und ob es vielleicht auch noch Ausbaupolizei gibt.
Hallo, Tobias Bäumler.
Thomas Abend, hallo.
Der Keck, der Dr. Keck ist das.
Freut uns sehr.
Für die Patienten ist es am Anfang so, gerade jetzt schon wieder so ein Telefonassistent.
Und dann stellen sie aber fest, okay, ich kann auch irgendwie am Sonntag nach der Tagesschau anrufen, mein Rezept vorbestellen.
Ich komme sofort dran, ich brauche nicht vier, fünf Mal anzurufen.
Ja, für sowas ist das, das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen, für sowas ist das praktisch.
Wir würden ja mal fragen, wie es quasi jetzt mit dem Neustart geglückt ist und auch die Möglichkeit mal besprechen,
was es eben für Ergänzungsmöglichkeiten bei VITAS auch noch gibt.
Die Angestellten sind sehr zufrieden, dass wir wieder zurück sind zu VITAS.
Das muss man ehrlich sagen.
Wir hatten inzwischen noch dieses kleine kurzzeitige Intermezzo bei jedem Konkurrenten.
Wir sehen sehr viele Wettbewerber und viele Kunden entscheiden sich auch wirklich für uns,
weil sie sagen, okay, der Wettbewerber bietet zwar einen Server in Frankfurt an,
aber der ist von Google und bei VITAS ist wirklich alles nur über deutsche Provider.
Wenn ich jetzt in Deutschland bei einer Arztpraxis anrufe, dann gehe ich eigentlich...
Na, laufen die auch bei Hetzner?
Ich bin nicht davon aus, als Patient, dass ich jetzt einmal über einen amerikanischen Server geleitet werde und da alle meine Daten hängen bleiben.
Was wir jetzt seit letztem Jahr auch noch mit im Angebot haben, ist die Möglichkeit eines Chatbots für die Website.
Funktioniert von der Logik und von der Konfiguration genauso wie der Telefonbot. Könnte sowas dann noch interessant sein.
Das ist sicherlich was, was die jüngere Generation, glaube ich, sicherlich gut findet, dass man sagt, ich muss gar nicht mehr ans Telefon oder ans Hörer greifen, sondern ich kann da einfach mein Boot schalten.
Wäre mir auch lieber.
Dann könnte man das testweise freischalten,
um das mal ausprobieren zu können.
Alles klar. Hat uns sehr gefreut.
Vielen Dank für den Besuch.
Dankeschön. Wir melden uns dann mit der Testphase.
Keck W.
Viel schneller als gedacht.
Im Grunde funktioniert es wie ein Telefonvertrag.
Die Abos unterscheiden sich im Funktionsumfang.
Kleine Unternehmen oder eine kleine Praxis
braucht nicht dasselbe wie ein großes Klinikum,
aber auch in der Anzahl der Anrufe.
Schön, dass sie es einrichten konnten.
Der Technik-Chef.
Oh, moin, moin, moin.
Ich gucke ja immer, was bin ich sehend?
HTML? Ne, Moment, Moment.
Doch, HTML?
NG? NG? Ist das Angular?
Sehe ich da irgendwas? NG? Template?
Angular? Stell's, hä?
Oder?
Ist das Chat?
Ihr kennt euch da besser mit aus.
Für mich sieht das tatsächlich aus,
wie Angular stellt.
Was erkenne ich da nicht?
Wirklich was?
Mini-Terminal, ja.
Eins noch mal.
Hier zwischen den Elementen, da habe ich jetzt mal die Abstände
ein bisschen angepasst, damit auch Zusammengehöriges
näher beieinander ist.
Am Anfang, das waren quasi zwei Jahre lang ununterbrochen.
Also das heißt von früh bis Abend und am Wochenende, weil auch der Ärger...
70 Stunden, ja, da wird halt Karriere gecrined, oder nee, nicht Karriere gecrined, das Startup-Mindset, Crined-Set.
...so groß war, das heißt wir wollten wirklich was machen, was nicht bloß irgendwie funktioniert,
sondern besser funktioniert als bei allen anderen Wettbewerbern.
Was viele oftmals unterschätzen ist, Software kann man ja nicht so richtig...
Jaja, das ist irgendein Angular-Zeug, oder? Wenn ich da schon NG und sowas lese.
Ja.
... oder so. Und von daher übersieht man da manchmal auch so den Aufwand und auch die Kosten, die einfach auch so dahinter stecken.
Wir haben hier in der Region unseren ersten Investor dann eben auch kennengelernt.
Der hat dann uns ein Ticket geschrieben in Höhe von 500.000 Euro.
Das war im Dezember 2020 und seitdem haben wir über mehrere Finanzierungsrunden insgesamt jetzt 3,6 Millionen Euro an Eigenkapital geraced.
Und darüber hinaus haben wir noch mal mehrere Millionen als Fremdkapital, als Darlehen dann quasi auch dann noch mal gezogen.
Tja, es gibt Leute, die haben da Feierabend, aber der Wechsel 17 Uhr ins Homeoffice.
Musste halt durch, ne?
Privatbereich, je nachdem wie viel Uhr es ist oder wie viele Termine waren, kann man abends mal noch mal ein paar E-Mails abarbeiten.
und so der letzte Kaffee des Tages dann beim Wechsel ins Homeoffice.
Aber Hauptsache erstmal die teure Kaffeemaschine am Start. Das muss, was muss, muss.
Hier ist jetzt so mein Homeoffice-Bereich im Vordergrund.
So, ich bin wieder da.
Es gibt Essen.
Wir gucken das aber noch fertig.
Ich habe jetzt hier Nudeln mit Lachs stehen, Leute.
Klassiker.
Wieder.
Am Sonntag.
So, gucken wir noch fertig.
Meine Sportecke im Hinteren.
Also grundsätzlich der ganze...
Ähm
Hier hat man einen Lenker drauf
Äh, Chat
Wisst ihr, wofür die Matte hier unten ist?
Ich hab auch sowas
Ratet mal, wofür die Matte ist
Schweiß, ja
Ich hab da auch so ein
Halbdurchsichtiges Plastikding drunter liegen
Dass man nicht den Teppich
Voll schwitzt
Wobei es viel besser ist
Hab ich mittlerweile gemerkt
wenn man sich hier oben drüber, also ich habe keinen Triathlon-Aufsatz,
wenn man sich hier einfach, ich habe halt so einen normalen Dropper-Lenker,
wenn man sich hier über den Lenker mit einem Handtuch drüber legt,
da geht 90% vom Geschwitze rein.
Und ich plane ja hier, mein Arbeitszimmer ein bisschen umzubauen,
also mit Basteltisch hier neben noch rein,
und ich muss aber halt erstmal ordentlich aufräumen.
Und hinten in die Ecke, da habe ich aktuell ein Sofa stehen.
Das Sofa, das habt ihr irgendwann mal in einem Video, falls ihr es gesehen habt, gesehen, wo ich mit der alten Katz drauf gehockt habe.
Da habe ich so ein Sofa hier in der Ecke stehen.
Das Sofa schmeiße ich raus.
Und dann stelle ich mein Fahrrad und Trainer da hinten hin, wo jetzt das Sofa steht.
Und da kommt dann auch ein Bildschirm hin.
Ein Mini-PC und einen Lüfter.
Nee, kein schwarzes Ledersofa, das ist ein rotes Sofa.
rotes Sofa.
Lüfter, weil es gibt mittlerweile
für Smart Trainer
Lüfter, die kann man koppeln
mit Swift zum Beispiel oder mit dem Smart Trainer
koppeln und die simulieren
Fahrtwind. Und das ist mega nice,
weil dann schwitzt du nicht so krass.
Ich meine, Luftfeuchtigkeit
gibt es trotzdem, aber es tropft dann
nicht so. Swift Streams.
Mit meinem Output
will das keiner sehen.
Ne, das baue ich nicht selber, da kaufe ich
irgendwas fertig. Das ist so, was ich mir so,
was mir so forscht, der ist aber recht teuer.
Tja, muss ich durch.
Das ist dann da hinten quasi, so die hintere
Wand, wird dann meine
Fahrradfahr-Ecke, wo ich dann auch schön im Winter
drauf Fahrrad fahren kann,
wenn kein schönes Wetter ist.
So, jetzt gucken wir aber erstmal fertig.
Aktivitätenbereich ist bei mir mal
ein Stockwerk höher gelegt. Mit 40 Stunden ist es nicht getan.
Man muss aber sagen, dass die
Wochenenden jetzt inzwischen schon deutlich
entspannter sind, als sie noch waren.
Chat, was haltet ihr davon?
Sorry, random Unterbrechung, random Frage.
Wollen wir heute Mittag mal wieder Stellenanzeigen angucken, Stream machen? Ich habe da irgendwie Bock drauf, nachdem wir uns heute die Bahnstellenanzeigen angeguckt haben. Könnten wir eigentlich mal wieder machen, oder? Das wäre doch mal wieder nice.
Ihr könnt ja schon mal ein paar Stellenanzeigen, die euch interessieren oder falls ihr welche habt, könnt ihr die euch schon mal bookmarken und mir nachher schicken. Dann gucken wir uns die zusammen an und ich gebe meinen Senf dazu.
So, next.
Sehr kleines Team waren, da hat man schon immer mal mehr Zeit.
Und in 2025 hatte ich jetzt auch erstmal den Urlaub, wo ich tatsächlich keinen Laptop dabei hatte.
Das war meine Woche komplett ohne Laptop unterwegs. Das war sehr schön.
Ganz am Anfang hatten wir einen 451-Euro-Job und die ersten größeren Gehälter waren dann nach der Finanzierungsrunde.
Wir haben angefangen mit so roundabout 3000 Euro brutto.
Das war so das erste Gehalt.
Und aktuell zahlen wir uns 5.750 Euro jeden Monat aus.
Brutto.
Alright, dann herzlich willkommen in der Wohnung.
Wir wohnen jetzt hier seit anderthalb Jahren und fühlen uns hier wirklich auch wohl.
Zwei Katzen wohnen hier eben auch noch, Nala und Balou.
Ja, super, einvollziehbar.
Exzellent.
Amen.
meistens stehe ich so gegen sechs uhr auf mich meistens hier auch noch mal
irgendwie in die küche trinken kaffee schon mal ein paar mails an
ja ich wollte die ganze zeit schon mal einen youtube video machen so aktueller stand und
so und um ich wenig bock drauf habe youtube videos zu machen und ich wollte youtube video
machen zum Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Da werde ich bestimmt wieder geflamed,
weil ich dann das sage, was ich
im Stream auch öfter schon gesagt habe,
dass ich nicht an das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops glaube,
sondern glaube, dass das eine schleichende Sache
sein wird und es auch
ganz entscheidend davon abhängig
sein wird, ob
Microsoft, und wovon ich persönlich
ausgehe, die nächsten Jahre weiterhin
verkacken wird bei Windows.
Da gehe ich von aus. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sie
die Kurve da kriegen.
oder chat was denkt ihr denkt ihr microsoft kriegt die kurve bei windows
die nächsten jahre noch oder die verkacken weiter
linux desktop ist auch mindset
da hat sich viel getan die letzten jahre auch vor allem durch die ganzen
influencers guck mal wer hätte vor ein paar jahren noch gedacht dass pewdiepie
Heimer Linux Videos macht.
Guten Morgen!
Grüß dich!
Gut hergefunden.
Und das Jahr hat bei euch gut angefangen?
Ja, super.
Also wir haben jetzt auch wieder alle Planzahlen erreicht und so.
Von daher hat alles gut geklappt.
Perfekt, das besprechen wir gleich noch im Detail.
Sehr gut.
Wenn ich am Ende des Jahres sage, wir haben uns verdoppelt, fragen die Investoren natürlich
gleich als erstes, warum habt ihr euch nicht verdreifacht?
Alright, dann herzlich willkommen, Investoren-Update Februar 26.
Freut mich, dass ihr alle mit dabei seid.
Wir hatten ja im Dezember unsere...
Ehrliche Antwort ist, es freut ihn nicht.
Er will ihr Geld, aber die soll möglichst die Klappe halten.
Es ist aber leider nicht so.
Ziele leicht übererfüllt.
Wir hatten 1.000 Euro MRR mehr,
als eigentlich ursprünglich auch geplant gehabt.
Der absolute Umsatz im Jahr ist sekundär.
Das, worauf die Investoren am meisten schauen,
ist wirklich dieser monthly recurring revenue, dieser skalierbare Lizenzumsatz, weil das auch etwas ist,
wo man als Unternehmen auch wirklich in der Lage ist, das mal zu verdreifachen, ohne das Team jetzt sonderlich zu skalieren.
Wir hatten jetzt die C5-Zertifizierung letzte Woche gehabt.
Datenschutz, Datensicherheit, Informationssicherheit ist ja ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Faktor bei uns.
Und die Zertifizierung ist jetzt eben auch super wichtig, weil auch viele größere Kunden auch danach gefragt haben.
Haben wir einen Überblick, wie die Wettbewerber da stehen? Sind die auch schon zertifiziert?
Ich würde sagen, so 95 Prozent der Wettbewerber haben keine Zertifizierung.
Perfekt.
Gut, wenn es ansonsten keine Fragen, Anmerkungen gibt, würde ich sagen, passt es für das kurze und knackige Investoren-Update. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Für uns ist einfach der Punkt Liquidität. Dann Wachstum. Wir wollten natürlich auch sehen, dass das Produkt einen echten Nutzen hat.
Und dann schaut man sich natürlich an, wie sieht der Gesamtmarkt aus und das alles in einem dann mit dem Team und das wir natürlich vor Ort einen anderen Bezug haben. Das ist dann das i-Tüpfelchen am Ende.
Jawohl, danke, dass du vorbeigekommen bist. Der Investor Call war gut.
also das sind eindeutig quasi eher die business leute ja wir haben jetzt wenig von der entwicklung
gesehen wenig von der technik dahinter gesehen aber das ist ja auch gut so kann ich alles können
und besser du hast da welche die richtig gut durchblicken und den kram auch verkaufen können
als umgedreht weil die bringt das beste produkt nichts wenn es keiner kennt wenn es nicht an die
leute bringst ich könnte mir vorstellen es sind bestimmt schon jede menge startups gescheitert
weil es dort und das sag ich jetzt wie gesagt als technik keller kind ja es gibt bestimmt genug
startups dies kunden irgendwelche leute die sich aus dem informatikstudium kennen die bau noch was
richtig geil ist aber das sind halt welche die das nicht verkaufen können dass da sind bestimmt
schon so viele Startups daran gescheitert.
Auf der anderen Seite umgedreht sicherlich auch.
Was bringen dir irgendwelche Gründer mit krassen Visionen
komplett realitätsfremd,
hör nicht auf irgendwelche Technikleute?
Das wird natürlich dann auch nichts.
Aber so eine Kombination ist da eigentlich am besten.
Diesmal haben auch die Zahlen und so weiter gestimmt.
Da ist es immer so ein bisschen entspannter.
Aber ja, alles gut.
Wirklich so seit 2023, 2024 machen wir wirklich exponentielle Umsätze.
Also in den letzten Monaten hatten wir jedes Mal von Monat zu Monat so einen Umsatzsprung, wie quasi in den ersten vier Jahren in Summe.
Man darf natürlich nicht unterschätzen, wie aufwendig die initiale Entwicklung und der Markteintritt überhaupt auch ist.
Da ist es dann einfach so, dass man am Anfang vor allem auch für diese Forschung, Entwicklung, Markteintritt eben auch diese externen Investoren eben auch benötigt.
Aktuell ist unser Ziel und unsere Strategie in den nächsten sechs Monaten wirklich diesen Break-Even zu erreichen,
dass wir uns dann auch wirklich ohne externe Investoren auch komplett selber tragen können.
Wie wenn in der Produktionshalle das Horn kommt und alle gehen gleichzeitig zum Essen.
Natürlich hat es sich mit zwei bis vier Vollzeitleuten schon angefühlt wie ein Unternehmen.
Und jetzt sind wir bei 40 und jetzt merkt man, bei 20 war es auch noch kein Unternehmen.
Oh, bei 40, da müssen die jetzt auch mehr Vorgaben, weil ich glaube, es gibt doch so eine Grenze bei unter 20 Mitarbeitern und sowas.
Wenn du unter 20 Mitarbeitern bist, musst du einige Sachen nicht machen, die du machen musst, wenn du über 20 Mitarbeiter bist.
Jetzt ist es ein Unternehmen, man spricht ja nicht mehr nur für sich, sondern man spricht eben auch von diesen anderen 40 Leuten,
die dann sich einen neuen Job suchen müssten, wenn es Mieters jetzt nicht mehr geben sollte.
Von dem her plant man da natürlich schon anders und spürt schon auch diesen Druck.
Klar.
Wir sind an einen Punkt gekommen, wo man sagt, man kann von dem Gehalt leben, gut leben.
Wir können immer noch das machen, worauf wir Lust haben.
Also ganz ehrlich, finanziell hat es sich nicht gelohnt bis jetzt für mich.
Ich würde sagen, wäre ich im Angestelltenleben geblieben, wäre wahrscheinlich mein Durchschnittsgehalt jetzt aktuell in den letzten Jahren mindestens das Doppelte gewesen.
Ich glaube aber, ich hätte es wahnsinnig bereut, wenn ich es nicht gemacht und nicht probiert hätte.
Dafür hat er da die Chance zu skalieren.
Dass es sich in der Zukunft auch finanziell lohnt, ist auf jeden Fall wahr.
Ja, das war doch ein gutes Video.
Auch wie gesagt, ich bin ja normalerweise nicht so der Fan von BWL-Leuten.
Aber das hat doch alles einen gut durchdachten Eindruck gemacht.
Und ich finde auch das Anwendungsgebiet nicht schlecht.
Oder das Einsatzgebiet nicht schlecht.
Ich habe letztens einen Termin gemacht bei einem Kardiologen für meine Mutter.
Und sie war dann da.
Und danach haben wir noch einen Zettel für den Hausarzt gebraucht.
Und da ist dort auch ein Chatbot dran gegangen.
Ich habe da angerufen, da ist ein Chatbot dran gegangen.
Die wollten dann wissen, bei welchem Arzt man war und Name, bla, sonst was und was man will.
Und dann hat man das dem Chatbot gesagt und es hat geklappt.
Der Chatbot hat dann nichts gemacht.
Der Chatbot ist im Endeffekt, hieß es dann nur, das ist jetzt aufgenommen, es meldet sich einer bei uns.
Ich gehe davon aus, derjenige, der dieses Ticket dann dort bekommt, ich nenne es mal Ticket,
irgendwie sowas werden die haben, ja, irgendeine Mitarbeiterin, Mitarbeiter dort,
wird dann dieses Ticket bekommen haben mit einer Zusammenfassung von dem Chatbot, was man will.
war dann schon beim Arzt und die haben dann angerufen hier und haben gesagt,
sie haben mit der Ärztin gesprochen, das und das und es ist jetzt in der Post.
Also da kann ich echt sagen, super, also sowas kann schon was bringen.
Vielleicht, und das ist, deswegen komme ich da gerade drauf,
vielleicht haben die ja auch den Chatbot von, ähm,
wie hießen die?
Vitas oder so.
Hier sind Vitas, oder?
Ja, das da.
Vielleicht haben die auch den Bot von denen.
Kann doch sein.
Karriere. Komm, wir gucken mal, was die für Jobs haben.
Offene Stellen.
Spontaneous Application.
Ey, Leute, ich hab absolut keine...
Ich wüsste noch nicht mal, was das ist.
So.
Ach, eine spontane Bewerbung.
Initiativbewerbung, sowas.
Ach, das ist damit gemeint.
Das habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt.
Okay, nur Sales, alles klar.
Naja.
Senior Business Development Manager.
Outbound.
Siehste, das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal kein Job für mich,
weil ich wüsste noch nicht mal anhand des Titels, was es überhaupt sein soll.
Ah ja. Gut, Leute. Dann machen wir heute Abend
wahrscheinlich oder heute Nachmittag wahrscheinlich
eine Runde Stellenanzeigen-Video.
OMG, könnte ich das sein? Was?
Def Outbound.
Dann mach mal Outbound-Dev.
Leute, ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Nudeln mit Lachs.
Wir hören uns dann wahrscheinlich später.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.